So, exzellent.
Das war das C-Mode.
Ja, ich hätte es fast vergessen, dass heute der 24. ist.
Deswegen habe ich heute etwas weihnachtliche Background-Musik an.
Und zwar die Christmas Special Relaxing Video Game Music.
Gucken, wie relaxing und Christmas special die so ist.
Ja, ich kann heute nicht rennen gehen, weil es ist richtig scheiß Wetter.
Also, ich bin da zwar relativ abgehärtet, aber das ist mir sogar zu viel.
Da habe ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Also, ich brauche nicht Sonnenschein und schönes Wetter unbedingt.
Aber die Temperaturen plus Regen ist echt scheiße.
Wie war der Windows ME Stream? Musst du gucken.
Keck, wait.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, Windows ME war gar nicht so scheiße, wie alle tun.
Ich meine, es war wieder der typische Windows Wahnsinn,
dass die Hälfte nicht...
funktioniert hat und laufen irgendwelche...
Also, Windows...
DOS-Windows-Linien-Probleme, dass es laufend irgendwelche komischen Fehler gab,
weil man wegen jedem Furz neu starten musste.
Aber das war jetzt ja klar.
Ja.
Es ist auf einmal...
Einmal spawnt das immer, dass das Weihnachten ist.
Weil wir gerade dabei sind.
Ist ja auch spawnt.
Anschliedungspackage-Updates.
Die spawnen auch.
Habe ich irgendwas gesnapshotted?
Aber bevor ich das mit dem Proxy installiert habe, da reverten wir mal auf den Snapshot und dann löschen wir den Snapshot und dann mache ich mal Package-Updates.
Bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist, kann ich Package-Updates machen.
Moin Max, feierst du Weihnachten?
Ja.
Nix jetzt nix super wildes, aber ich würde mal sagen, so das, was wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute an Weihnachten machen.
Was ordentliches Futtern.
Ja.
Bisschen Geschenke stellt.
Und eigentlich war es das schon, also ich meine, entweder mache ich Stream heute Abend, da können sich dann alle sammeln, die keinen Bock auf Weihnachten haben oder irgendwie nicht Weihnachten feiern, niemanden haben, mit dem sie Weihnachten feiern, keine Ahnung, vielleicht mache ich Stream heute Abend, oder ich mache MMO-Kreise-Crime, je nachdem, muss ich mal gucken.
Was ist das denn?
Replace D-Stat extra wie Duel.
Nicht Tool, Duel.
Okay, D-Stat ist anscheinend outdated.
Overrated, G-Bated, alles klar.
Warum?
Was ist das Problem?
Was, okay, Github, Moment, mal kurz gucken.
Was ist, was ist Duel?
Ungewöhnlich, nicht Tool.
Duel.
Ein Python 3 kompatibler Fork of D-Stat.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass D-Stat bisher schon immer, äh, soll mir recht sein.
Ach ja, und ich habe ein Video aufgenommen.
Lade ich nachher hoch, wenn der Stream fertig ist.
Erinnert mich nämlich gerade die Background-Musik dran, weil diese, diese Background-Musik habe ich...
...ja, auch im Video als Hintergrund.
Was gibt's bei euch zu futtern?
Hirsch.
Oder Reh.
Ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, was es ist.
Und, äh, ob das überhaupt unterschiedlich schmeckt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher Reh.
Es könnte aber auch Hirsch sein.
Und das ist übelst teuer.
Also, ich meine, das ist schon immer teuer, aber dieses Jahr ist es wirklich übertrieben teuer.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie krass teuer manche Sachen sind?
Also, natürlich wisst ihr das, ne?
Aber...
Hirsch ist quasi...
Aha.
Aha, ist der der Kenner.
Kenner spricht.
Ähm, aber, ich meine, ihr habt natürlich, ihr habt das natürlich auch mitgekriegt.
Aber, mir ist das Letzte aufgefallen.
Ich habe im Lidl einen Wagen eingekauft.
Der war...
Also, du hast noch ohne Probleme den kompletten Boden gesehen, ja?
An manchen Ecken stand was im Einkaufswagen rum.
Knapp 50 Euro.
Da war, da war, also...
Nicht viel drin.
Und am Ende habe ich mal geguckt.
Ein, also, ein nicht unerheblicher Teil von den 50 Euro war.
Jetzt haltet euch fest, jetzt wird es super advanced.
Ein paar billige...
Was billige?
Also, billig war es nicht, preislich.
Ein Pack...
Tintenfischringe.
Und so Soße zum Dippen für die Tintenfischringe.
Allein schon das hat irgendwie 8 Euro oder sowas gekostet, Alter.
Also, 3 Euro die Soße oder so.
Das war mega teuer.
Was ist denn da los, Mann?
Memoji-Update.
Beste.
Schnabber.
Ich meine, für 8 Euro konntest du in Frankfurt vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit Nudel mit Hähnchen beim Chinesfuddern.
Chinesfuddern.
Mittagsmenü.
War gar kein Problem.
Und das war eine Riesenportion, was du da gekriegt hast.
Dann, oder, oder, oder, oder, Reis mit Hähnchen, Nudel mit Hähnchen, ist ja wurscht.
Irgendwas in der Richtung hast du da Mittagsmenü ohne Probleme gekriegt.
Und du bezahlst da wahrscheinlich 12 Euro für.
So, alles geupdatet, aber hat ja keinen Sinn.
Deswegen sollen sie sich nicht mal beschweren.
Ich habe ja letztens diesen Heise-Artikel gelesen, wo sie, wo sich...
Ähm, die...
Arbeitgeber wieder bei Bitkom beschwert haben, dass der Fachkräftemangel so, so extrem ist.
Und sie unterm Strich halt einfach nicht für wenig Geld super kompetente Leute finden.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ja gut, Pech gehabt.
Wir müssen auch gucken, wo wir bleiben.
Also mal davon abgesehen.
Wir müssen das immer gucken, wo wir bleiben.
Ups.
Aber aktuell, wenn das Zeug so teuer ist, muss man ja nochmal doppelt gucken, wo man bleibt.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich mir immer denke, ich labere gerade random Zeug.
Ich hatte nichts mit dem Stream zu tun.
Also doch, schon mit dem Stream.
Hatte nichts irgendwie mit dem, äh, was wir jetzt machen.
Deswegen kann ich auch nicht so verstehen, dass die, oder nicht ganz, doch, verstehen schon, aber nicht ganz nachvollziehen, dass die Leute sich immer so krass über irgendwelche Management-Chef-Gehälter aufregen.
Weil, der hat einen Arbeitsvertrag, wie ihr auch, bekommen.
Und irgendjemand hat den gemacht.
Über die könnte man sich aufregen, warum es da so viel Geld für gibt.
Aber es ist halt einfach auch so, dass es nicht viele gibt, die diese Position machen wollen, machen können, oftmals.
Und sich jetzt darüber aufzuregen, dass die Leute dann darauf bestehen, was in ihrem Arbeitsvertrag ist, auch zu bekommen, das finde ich gar nicht so verwerflich.
Verwerflich ist eher, warum der Arbeitsvertrag so aussieht, wie er aussieht.
Was ich natürlich, was ich aber ein bisschen fragwürdig finde, ist, wenn es Sachen gibt, die von Steuern finanziert werden, oder aber, oder aber von, sagen wir mal, sowas ähnliches wie Steuern.
Sowas wie, ähm, Rundfunkgebühren, zum Beispiel.
Das sind ja nicht wirklich Steuern, aber es ist schon nicht so weit davon entfernt, Steuern zu sein.
Und, äh, wenn davon dann unbedingt Leute, die dort gearbeitet haben, mehrere Millionen als Rente haben wollen, da denke ich mir auch, das muss jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt sein.
Wenn ich die Chance hätte, keine Rundfunkgebühren zu bezahlen, würde ich auch keine Rundfunkgebühren bezahlen.
Da sage ich euch ganz ehrlich, ich bin nicht dafür, dass man das abschafft.
Im Gegenteil, ich finde das nicht schlecht, einen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zu haben.
Aber, und das ist das, wo es ein bisschen ausufert, meiner Meinung nach, die müssen nicht wirklich alles das machen, was sie jetzt gerade machen.
Ich brauche nicht, äh, Maxi Ahland, Hansi Hinterseer und Florian Silbereisen in der hundertsten dicke Backen Volksmusikshow.
Oder, äh.
Was weiß ich, 350 regionale Radiosender oder so ein Ding.
Also, da könnte man vielleicht sich aufs Wesentliche besinnen und gut wäre.
Chris DI, danke schön für den Sub.
Was kostet ein Döner?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, was bei uns ein Döner kostet.
Ich kann dir sagen, was ein Döner Teller kostet.
Döner Teller ist ja im Prinzip der Döner ohne, ja, ohne Brot, dafür mit Reis oder mit Pommes frites.
Wobei das natürlich nicht stimmt.
Das ist jetzt so die, die jebaited.
Die Antwort, Döner Teller ist natürlich meistens deutlich mehr Fleisch und Salat und Zeug, alles noch drauf, als in Döner selbst reinpasst.
Also, ich kann dir sagen, was ein Döner Teller kostet.
Ein Döner Teller kostet bei uns gerade zwölf Euro, beim Dönerladen um die Ecke.
Ich habe schon ewig keinen richtigen Döner mehr geholt, sondern immer Döner Teller.
Ich finde, irgendwie schmeckt mir das besser ohne, ohne.
Zumal, zumal man bei uns beim Döner Teller auch noch so ein Stück Brot dabei kriegt.
Da könnte man theoretisch schon mal.
Wenn sich ein Döner daraus basteln.
Zwölf Euro ohne Getränk, einfach nur der Döner Teller.
Also das ist nicht, nicht ganz billig alles mittlerweile.
Ja, zumindest mir schmeckt das besser und ich lasse mir immer noch extra dabei.
So weiß ich wie das wie diese türkische scharfe Sauce heißt, die man noch dabei kriegt.
Die kann man nicht irgendwie drüber klatschen lassen, aber ich lasse mir die meistens gerne dabei geben.
Da kann ich mir die selbst drüber hauen.
Ja, das war mal bei 3,50.
Gibt's da nicht irgendwo?
Irgendwo in Deutschland gibt es doch so eine ganz berühmte Wand.
Vielleicht kennt das jemand.
Ich kenne das nur von Reddit Posts.
Es gibt doch irgendwo in Deutschland gibt es so eine ganz berühmte Wand, wo irgendeiner
dran gesprayt hat Döner 3,50 und wo die Leute immer drauf verweisen, wie teuer das geworden
ist oder Döner 3 Euro oder irgendwie sowas.
Spray Wand Dönerpreis Deutschland findet man nicht.
Nee.
Das finde ich gerade nicht.
Versuchen.
In Berlin.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es in Berlin ist.
Also ich habe die.
Ich habe das schon jetzt sehr oft auf Reddit gesehen, dieses Foto von der einen Wand, wo
einer so mit Graffiti Dosen dran gesprüht hat.
Vor frag mich nicht wahrscheinlich 20 Jahren oder so Döner 3 Euro oder Döner 3,50 oder
sowas oder Döner 2 Euro oder irgendwie so ganz niedrige Dönerpreis.
Und das wird auf Reddit immer, immer gepostet, wenn es um neue Dönerpreise geht.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Da postet immer irgendjemand dieses Bild von dieser Wand, wo da steht Döner hier 2, 2 Euro
oder 3 Euro.
Dönerbremse.
Ja, hat ja, hat ja bei der Mietbremse schon alles wunderbar funktioniert, mehr gebremst
werden.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Bremse sind, kurzer, kurzer, kurze Story.
Es gab bei uns auf der Arbeit gab es mal eine E-Mail Bremse, wo wir gerade beim Bremsen
sind.
Wenn die Leute wieder zu viel gespammt haben und das alles nicht hinterhergekommen ist,
dann gab es eine E-Mail Bremse.
Ich überlege mir gerade, wie die E-Mail Bremse funktioniert hat.
Wahrscheinlich wurde einfach am Eingang keine Mails mehr angenommen oder ja gedrosselt, wie
viel Mails angenommen werden können.
Und dann ist es halt bei denen in der Outbox geblieben und wurde dann wieder neu verschickt.
Also in der alten Arbeit hatten wir eine Mail Bremse.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ja, bei der Bank.
Nicht bei der Bank.
Bei der Bahn.
Da ist die Bremse das kleinste Problem.
Es ist jetzt ja zu Weihnachten wieder ganz unerwartet voll in den Zügen.
Leute, damit hätte niemand rechnen können.
Auch als letztes die Bahn.
Also wie könnte man damit rechnen, dass es an Weihnachten oftmals schlechtes Wetter ist
und die Züge voll sind?
Das ist, kommt, kam noch nie vor.
Noch nie.
Das kann man nicht wissen.
Unmöglich.
Unmöglich zu prädikten.
Habt ihr auch euer E-Mail Server ist Shit?
Gibt es Chatgear?
Gibt es irgendeinen E-Mail Server oder irgendjemand, der sich um E-Mails kümmert, der nicht denkt,
dass das Shit ist?
Ich glaube, jeder, der was mit E-Mails macht, denkt, dass das Shit ist.
Habe ich das eigentlich schon rebooted?
War gar nicht sicher.
Ja, habe ich.
Ja, mein letztes.
Egal.
Nochmal rebooten.
Rebooted schadet nichts.
E-Mail ist immer Shit.
Sie haben ja ECEs rausgegeben.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Immerhin.
Immerhin hat man zumindest versucht, weil in der Vollendung kriegt die Bahn das natürlich
nicht hin.
Aber immerhin hat man versucht mitzudenken.
Reboot tut gut.
Das ist fast wie unter Windows ME.
Da mussten wir ja auch laufen und rebooten.
Habt ihr eigentlich gesehen?
Chatgear, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Es gibt neue Hintergründe.
White, Pepo, Head.
Das ist ja so.
White, Pepo, Happy, Background.
Warte, mal kurz gucken, ob ich meine Toolbox JetBrains Sachen aktualisieren muss.
Äh, hallo?
Äh.
Toolbox?
Ok.
Hat die sich gerade aktualisiert und startet sich jetzt neu?
Oder ist die gerade geprocken?
Ne, sie aktualisiert sich.
Ich meinte, JetBrains, wie wäre es mit so einem kleinen Hinweis, Toolbox updatet sich
oder so was?
wow weil die haben ja alles raus gehauen hier 23 punkt 3 sie leihen wofür haben wir das noch
mal verwendet ach so als wird ordentlich an den stall an den stall frauen ich rast bald
mal go land und peitscher und rider behalten wir auch ok update ich muss sagen ich war jetzt schon
zwei tage nicht mehr rennen weil ich mir gedacht habe bringt jetzt nix weil sonst müsstest du zwei
tage hintereinander rennen und natürlich schienbein weh warte mal bis sonntagmorgen da
gehst du eh rennen und jetzt ist scheiß wetter und ich bin nicht rennen und irgendwie habe ich jetzt
habe ich permanent das gefühl es dadurch dass ich jetzt nicht rennen gehe werde ich langsamer
so was was theoretisch gesehen ja auch so ist aber so minimal dass es nicht wirklich ins gewicht
fällt aber trotzdem
ich habe jetzt den eindruck ich habe nachdem ich jetzt quasi den dritten tag in folge nicht gerannt
bin so ich bin es ist so längst überfällig ist halt gerade geht es nicht guck mal direkt man
hat neues hat neue bilder neue bilder geschickt und zwar es gibt jetzt recycle story was ich ja
persönlich sehr nice finde ich wollte es nicht runterladen wollte es einfach nur anzeigen
alter meine güte firefox keyquake also es gibt neues bild recycle story in der sunset variante
warum auch immer sein set ich weiß nicht wie cycles darin wir nur wenn es dunkel wird und
dann haben wir noch ein bastel champ deluxe hands are am start das machte aber tagsüber also gibt zwei
neue zwei neue images heißt ihr müsst falls ihr die als background images verwendet ihr
einmal das getriebe pullen oder im neuen images runterladen exzellente ich bin echt müde ich habe
zu viel mmo kreise kreidet aber auch noch eine habe auch noch nicht angeguckt meine güte hast
du eine idee ich habe eine lampe von amazon kauft wo was von das motor eine wertung hat aber ich
bin nicht wirklich ein passendes wieder aus youtube wie man vorgeht naja da kann ich ja
was zu erzählen und zwar was ist es erstmal ein link zu der lampe da können wir mal zusammen
gucken oder die produkt die produktbezeichnung oder was was auch immer irgendwas wo wir gucken
können also ich kann dir zeigen wo du gucken musst du musst hier gucken auf der seite und
dann suchst du mal danach ok also die lampe hier
das ist okay das ist irgendein china chinesen ding was ist wahrscheinlich tausendfach in
verschiedenen reseller geschichten gibt ich habe können ok das ist die us variante davon du musst
mal gucken auf was das ganze basiert als man das irgendwie rausfindet zumindest kannst du auf der
seite suchen
ja das bringt dir aber das ist das dass das tuja ist das ist das meiste aber manche geräte haben ja
bestimmte kombinationen wie man in den update modus kommt oder in also kannst du kannst hier mal gucken
hier lights leds hier findest du das hast sogar mit mit bild kannst du was raussuchen was so ähnlich
ausschaut dann guckst du dir die anleitung an dazu also sagen wir jetzt mal du hättest keine ahnung
immer mal keine anwalt ist das da gekauft ja
dann hast du hier unten was meistens auf der seite der anleitung wie du in den flash modus kommst und auch hinweise darauf ob die
neuen geräte versionen beispielsweise das gar nicht mehr unterstützen du hast zwei varianten prinzipiell
wenn das ding ein esp 86 oder 1 sp 32 anhält also zwei varianten oder flächen da flächen ist relativ
einfach funktioniert aber meistens nicht mehr da kannst du also wenn du ots flächen willst kannst du auch mal in der
in der Stream-History gucken, da haben wir ein paar Sachen.
Da kannst du das hier benutzen.
Das Ding ist halt, die meisten
neuen Geräte funktionieren
mit OTA-Flashen nicht mehr.
Von der Idee her
ist das relativ simpel. Du brauchst
ein Raspberry Pi, checkst das Git-Report
auf und startest Start-Flash.
Vorher führst du Installation
aus, ja.
Von Abhängigkeiten dann startest
du Start-Flash. Und was das Ding macht
ist, wenn ich das noch richtig im Kopf
habe, das erstellt
ein WLAN mit der SSID
wie der Hersteller
in China verwendet hat, um das
Gerät initial zu programmieren
und die Dinger waren halt so blöde, gestrickt
in der Firmware, dass sie sich zu
jedem WLAN connecten, was diese
SSID hat und von
dort von einer bestimmten IP ihr
Firmware-Image runterladen.
Du brauchst halt
ein Raspberry Pi,
das Skript
musst du starten, du brauchst noch ein Tablet
im WLAN drin, oder ein
Smartphone in diesem WLAN drin und dann
funktioniert es. Also das ist
was funktioniert über OTA,
aber vieles mit OTA funktioniert nicht.
Vieles funktioniert nicht mit OTA.
Das heißt, wenn du Pech hast,
musst du ein ESP32
an den Punkten
anlöten zum Flashen. Dazu
brauchst du einen Serial-Flasher.
USB auf Serial
Flash-Cham.
Das ist auch nicht schwierig,
da gibt es, kannst du bei Amazon
gucken hier,
bei Amazon gucken,
ESP32 Flash,
also das ist gar kein ESP32
spezifischer Flasher,
sowas hier in der Richtung braucht man da, guck.
Das hat auf der einen Seite USB,
auf der anderen Seite hast du ein paar
Pinheader, oder kannst du auch die Sachen
anlöten und im Endeffekt läuft das so, guck,
du kannst es auch für Arduino verwenden, ist vollkommen egal.
Ich benutze so ein Ding von ESP32,
du schaltest hier oben um
von 5 auf 3,3,
je nachdem was du verwendest, beim Raspberry Pi
musst du auf
5, äh nicht beim Raspberry Pi,
beim Arduino musst du auf 5,
beim Arduino, beim ESP32
musst du unbedingt auf 3,3,
weil es gibt einige Boards, die
da keine 5 Volt über die
Pins vertragen,
über die GPIO-Pins vertragen
und dann schließt du dein RX
an, dein TX an, immer dran denken,
RX und TX vertauschen,
Chatgewehr ist High IQ, wer weiß,
warum man RX und TX vertauschen muss,
also was ich meine ist,
RX hier muss auf TX
vom Board und TX hier muss auf
RX vom Board, das liegt daran,
weil du sonst quasi die,
nennen wir es mal die Transmission
Pin auf den Transmission
Pin legst und den Receive Pin
auf den Receive Pin legst, das willst du ja nicht.
Du willst ja den Receive Pin
auf den Transmission Pin und den
ähm, ja,
Transmission Pin auf den Receive Pin,
genau, der Chat weiß es.
Deswegen musst du das über Kreuz machen
und im Endeffekt musst du, um zum Flashen,
du musst RX und TX über Kreuz
anschließen an einem ESP32,
du schließt VCC an, den 3,3
Volt Pin an und Ground.
Das war's, bei manchen
Raspberry Pis musst du noch
GPIO,
boah, das weiß ich jetzt nicht aus dem Kopf,
2 ist es glaube ich, GPIO 0 oder GPIO 2
musst du noch auf Ground
stöpseln.
Bei manchen Raspberry Pis, dass die
in den Flash-Modus gehen.
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter, also
mit Abstand am einfachsten ist
wirklich das Konvertieren
mit Tuya Convert, aber du
findest halt viele Sachen,
also du findest nicht mal viele Sachen, die das
über OTA unterstützen.
Und der hat 2020
was von Tasmota geschrieben,
also es könnte durchaus sein, dass das jetzt aktuell
nicht mehr funktioniert, wenn da was mit
Tasmota steht.
Äh, ESP, nicht Raspberry Pi.
WTF, ja, ja, ja, ESP,
ihr habt recht. So,
Icos, jetzt weißt du Bescheid.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit sich das jetzt was gebracht hat,
aber die Chance, dass das noch OTA
flashbar ist, ist relativ gering.
Wenn du Glück hast, ist noch
ein ESP32 drin, oder ein ESP2866,
dann kannst du es aufmachen
und löten, wobei ganz ehrlich,
Lampen aufmachen und löten
ist doof. Die meisten Lampen gehen nicht
gescheit auf. Also wahrscheinlich
ist es besser, du schickst es wieder zurück.
Du kannst mal OTA flashen und probieren.
Ich persönlich vermute aber,
dass die neueste Version hier von,
wahrscheinlich gar kein ESP32
mehr drin hat.
Wie macht ESPHome das eigentlich über WLAN?
Ja, ESPHome updatet über WLAN.
Hast du schon mal bei Linux mit
Nice? Ja, hab ich. Ist aber schon ewig her.
Warum? Braucht man meistens auch nicht.
So Prozesspriorität und so ist es
meistens ziemlich egal. Der Scheduler macht das schon ganz gut.
Uah.
So.
Das Gehalt als Customer Success Manager.
Weiß ich nicht, haben wir uns das schon
angeguckt?
Kann sein.
Was haben wir denn hier zu gucken?
Wie reich sind sie denn?
Im Internet steht 1,4 Milliarden.
Alles klar.
YouTube Shorts, man.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Wenn man einmal angefangen hat,
YouTube Shorts zu gucken, dann scrollst
du die ganze Zeit weiter.
Welche sinnlosen Shorts.
Was kostet das hier?
Alles Helm.
Was auch immer.
Wie reich sind sie denn?
Ja, super.
Kratsch.
Das interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Das hat man schon.
Das interessiert mich gar nicht, wie reich er ist.
Hast du schon mal eine Erfahrung mit Antiklärfolie vom Monitor entfernt?
Ne, nur vom Handy.
So, jetzt müssen wir das machen, was wir jeden Sonntagmorgen machen.
Und zwar, wir gucken einmal in die Shithubtrends, was da so, was da so trendet in der Woche.
Irgendwas Interessantes dabei ist.
YouTube Shorts ist der gleiche.
Ich muss sagen, ich gucke tatsächlich, ich meine, es kann sich ja der Sache kaum einer entziehen.
Ja.
Probier OTA zu flashen.
Aber ich, also ich persönlich fürchte, die Lampe, die du gekauft hast, danke IKOS für
den Sub, ich fürchte, die Lampe, die du gekauft hast, hat gar kein ESP32 mehr drin.
Also viele neue Sachen haben kein ESP32 drin.
Leider.
Also, was trendet denn diese Woche auf GitHub?
Wir skippen wie immer.
AI.
Ich vermute mal auch AI.
A language for writing HTML user interfaces in Go.
Das haben wir letzte Woche schon gehabt.
Und ich habe mich letzte Woche schon gefragt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie React, nur in Go.
Guckt, guckt euch das an.
Ich finde, es sieht ein bisschen aus wie React, nur in Go.
Und ich habe mich da so gefragt.
But why?
Also, ich meine nicht React, sondern halt dieses.
Wie heißt das in React?
Das, ähm, HTML, JSX meine ich.
Also, HTML in JavaScript gedöhnt.
Und das sieht halt aus wie HTML in Go.
Moin, Blackripper.
Also, das ist wirklich das, wo ich ein bisschen denke, warum?
Warum HTML in Go?
Man könnte, man könnte auch einfach HTML in HTML machen.
Wäre auch eine Möglichkeit.
So, hier gibt es China-Chinesen-Android-App.
Wir wissen wieder nicht, was es ist.
Also, übersetzen in Englisch.
Customized screen-based...
Was?
Ich habe seriously keine Ahnung anhand der Beschreibung, was es ist.
Chat, checkt irgendjemand, was das sein soll?
Customized screen-based on accessibility advanced selector subscription rules click Android-App.
Ist das so was wie Tasker?
Nur auf Chinesisch?
Click to skip any open screen ads.
Ah!
Das ist ein Popup, Popup-Close-Ding.
Wenn Popups aufploppen, dann klickt er die weg für dich.
Stonks-Craft.
Okay.
Open-Source-Alternative to Airdrop.
Das finde ich eine coole Sache.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Aber ich stelle mir das, also ich stelle es mir sehr praktisch vor.
Wenn man von seinem iPhone zum PC airdroppen kann.
Das geht damit.
Das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Also, wir haben es noch nie ausprobiert im Stream, aber wir haben das Projekt, haben
wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Dann gibt es Oxts.
Das haben wir auch schon gesehen.
JavaScript-Zeug in Rust.
Weil die Krustentiere gerne, habe ich zumindest den Eindruck, gerne Probleme lösen, die es
gar nicht gibt.
So.
Dann haben wir was, wo ich nicht weiß, was es ist, was auch keine Beschreibung hat.
Next.js, so ein Template-Projekt.
Server & Web-Application für Open-Source-Teams-Chat.
Okay.
Man merkt das gleich, dass ich heute deutlich früher am Start bin.
Weniger Leute.
Und es ist Weihnachten, die Leute schlafen heute länger.
Bytebase.
Worlds most advanced database DevOps and continuous integration delivery for DevOps.
Okay.
Delivery for DevOps.
Was?
The GitLab for Database.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Manchmal wäre eine etwas, also eine Funktionsbeschreibung besser als eine, wie soll man sagen, eine Visionsbeschreibung.
The only database.
Was ist das?
Old World.
Bytebase.
Ich.
Different database development has multiple.
Ich check's immer noch nicht.
Die Musik wird richtig.
Will es richtig wissen im Hintergrund gerade.
Chat, wenn ihr dieses Bild so seht, versteht ihr, was das ist?
Also ich kann mir da was.
Ich kann mir da was zusammen reiben.
Und zwar.
Dass man.
Auch verschiedene oder verschiedenste Technologien und.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Sachen.
Cloud.
Dinger.
Datenbanken zugreifen kann.
Mit einem einheitlichen Interface.
Aber.
Also ganz gecheckt habe ich es immer noch.
Das Bild finde ich hilft jetzt auch nicht sonderlich.
Mir das zu erklären.
Also.
Hundertprozentig.
Das ist so eine Art Ticketsystem für Datenbank Änderung oder sowas.
Okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Scheint High IQ Zeug zu sein, wo ich gerade nicht in der Lage bin, das zu verstehen.
Go Wizard.
Du bist.
Du bist gerade ein bisschen zu spät am Start.
Danke für den Sub.
Wir haben uns gerade gefragt, was der Sinn davon ist.
Aber als Go Wizard wirst du das wahrscheinlich wissen.
Warum man beispielsweise hier HTML in Go machen will und man nicht einfach HTML in HTML macht.
Vielleicht weißt du das als Go Wizard.
Oder wollen die dort Server Site Rendering für Go erfinden?
Was es ja im Endeffekt ist.
HTML.
Strings mit ein paar.
Template Elementen, wo was eingesetzt wird, je nach Request.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, weil man viele Fotos macht.
Das habe ich schon öfters gesehen.
Also wenn ich, wenn ich der große Fotografierer wäre, dann hätte ich das auch am Start.
Das ist das ist lokale Bildverwaltung für seine für seine Bilder.
Man kann.
Man kann glaube ich sogar damit.
Genau.
Man kann damit sogar Videos sinken.
Nicht Videos, Videos und Fotos sinken vom Handy und so.
Das ist echt cool.
Also würde ich, würde ich viele Fotos machen, die es wert wären, gesunken zu werden und Backup zu werden.
Dann hätte ich das wahrscheinlich auch am Start.
Okay, wieder ein weiteres Tool in Rust.
Wo man nicht weiß, warum.
Rare and Exotic Stats.
Was?
Ort ist ein Index, Block, Exporter und Command Line.
Ah, Krypto Stels.
Also anhand dieses Titels.
Wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, dass es Rare and Exotic Stats.
Nee, nee, Sets.
Nicht Stats.
Sets.
Dann hätte ich noch weniger gecheckt.
Hätte ich nicht gecheckt, dass es sich hier um irgendwelche Krypto Sachen handelt.
Ort.
AI, AI, AI.
China-Chinesen Zeug.
Weekly.
Ah, ein ein Technologie, ein chinesischer Technik Newsletter.
C++, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
AI.
Noch mehr China-Chinesen Zeug.
Hört ja gar nicht mehr auf heute.
Okay.
Hands on Deep Learning.
Okay, es ist chinesisches AI Zeug.
Und AI.
Tja.
Also diese Woche ist ja wirklich sehr AI-heavy.
Ich würde mal sagen, 60% aller Projekte, die wir heute hier gesehen haben, ist AI gewesen.
Das skippe ich ja mittlerweile aus Prinzip.
Weil das meiste geht mir auf den Keks.
Also weil es immer wieder der gleiche Krempel ist.
In zig unterschiedlichen Sprachen.
Und ich würde das meiste gar keinen Anwendungszweck haben.
Gut, dass daran entwickelt wird.
Aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt bin ich die meisten der Projekte dort nicht sonderlich spannend.
Chat, seid ihr schon in Weihnachtsstimmung?
Also ich muss sagen, ich nicht wirklich.
Also ich weiß, dass der 24. ist.
Vielleicht wenn wir das ASCII-Quarium anmachen.
Wobei das ja nicht zweilachtlich ist.
Hat ne.
Aber ich weiß, dass der 24. ist.
Aber so wirklich, dass ich mir jetzt denke.
Jawoll Weihnachten.
Irgendwie ist das auch nicht.
Bei euch sieht es aus wie Mitte Frühling.
Ja, bei uns auch.
Bei uns ist 6 Grad.
Und es regnet.
As fuck.
Wobei es ein bisschen weniger geworden ist.
Theoretisch könnte ich jetzt ne Runde rennen gehen.
Aber jetzt habe ich schon angefangen zu streamen.
Jetzt gehe ich auch keine Runde mehr rennen.
Mini-Distribution.
Meinst du jetzt zum Ausprobieren?
Oder wirklich Linux, was hauptsächlich für Kubernetes ausgelegt ist?
Also für mich ist das einfachste immer noch zum lokalen Ausprobieren.
Mini-Cube.
Hehe.
Ne.
Dann seht ihr ja wo ich wohne.
Cake Wait.
Ich mag Mini-Cube.
Das ist schon simpel.
Starten.
Deleten.
Und weg.
Jetzt wieder.
Dafür habe ich uns ein bisschen weihnachtliche Musik angemacht.
In der Hoffnung, dann ist es nicht.
Dann ist mehr Weihnachtsstimmung angesagt.
Wir gucken jetzt noch mal schnell.
Ich habe nämlich gesehen.
Wir haben ja noch eine Stellenanzeige übrig, die ich mir angucken sollte.
Die irgendjemand gepostet hat.
Ich weiß nicht mehr wer es gewesen ist.
Moment, das hatten wir doch schon, oder?
Ne, hatten wir doch nicht.
Hatten wir das schon?
Ist derjenige da, der es gepostet hat?
Wenn nicht, macht es jetzt eigentlich keinen Sinn zu gucken.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich bin echt immer noch übertrieben müde, Leute.
Ich habe übrigens gestern Abend noch was aufgenommen für YouTube.
Plane ich nachher hoch.
Weihnachtsansprache.
Gestern.
Gestern kurz vor 24 Uhr war ich fertig mit MMO Kreiselgrind.
Und irgendwie war es mir danach was aufzunehmen.
Plane ich nachher dann hoch.
Was haben wir denn?
Was können wir uns denn hier heute auf YouTube mal angucken?
Was?
Nein.
Wir haben überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun.
Aber davon abgesehen.
Guckt euch meine Aufrufzahlen auf Twitch an.
Keck Wait.
Sonst wird das irgendjemand jucken.
Außerdem.
Ich würde auch nicht auf irgendwelche Events gehen.
Ihr wisst, wie sehr ich auf Offline-Events und Kontakt mit anderen Menschen stehe.
Also.
Das ist alles nichts für mich.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Was können wir uns hier angucken?
IT-Job ohne Abschluss.
Das hat doch irgendjemand im Chat gepostet.
Das Gehalt als Customer Success Manager.
Oh, das klingt irgendwie nach Bullshit-Job, oder?
Was macht denn ein Customer Success Manager?
Ich weiß mittlerweile immerhin, was ein Key Account Manager ist.
Aber bei allen den fancy Begriffen blicke ich auch nicht durch.
Er sitzt zumindest schon mal an einem Mac.
Okay, dann.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Endlich bereit für Half-Life 6.
Ha!
GameStar!
G-Baid!
Ich glaube nichts mehr, was zum Thema Half-Life 3 kommt, Mann.
Das sind bestimmt die, die dir in die Kommentare schreiben.
Ich weiß nicht, was macht...
Okay, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal kurz angucken, was ein Customer Success Manager macht.
What is a Customer Success Manager?
So.
Okay, Wikipedia.
This article has multiple issues.
Enhancing Customer Satisfaction.
Gibt's das vielleicht auch ohne Bullshit?
Gibt's da irgendwie eine gescheite Erklärung auf Deutsch?
Der Chat ist jetzt so...
Englisch für Kundenerfahrung...
Okay, das hätte ich mir auch noch selbst übersetzen können.
Aber damit kann ich jetzt auch nicht so viele anfangen.
satisfaktion
bef protests
Okay, bezeichne die konsequente Ausrichtung eines Unternehmens auf den Erfolg seiner Kunden.
Ja okay, das sagen die natürlich.
Wenn es den Kunden gut geht und die happy sind,
dann ist im Prinzip das Geld, was reinkommt, auch happy.
Was auch immer.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an, was ein Customer Success Manager so treibt...
Schlimmer, schlimmer als die Unternehmensberaterin,
kopiert, kann es nicht sein.
Welcome, I'm Yashi.
Ich habe keine
abgeschlossene Ausbildung, kein abgeschlossenes Studium.
How much does it cost?
Das ist doch, das ist
in der heutigen Zeit,
wenn viele Quereinsteiger gesucht, warum nicht?
Hello, welcome, I'm Yashi.
Ich habe keine
abgeschlossene Ausbildung, kein abgeschlossenes Studium.
How much does it cost?
Ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, jada, jada, jada, right?
Ich bin mir dessen bewus...
Ich wusste, dass ich zu den
Topverdienenden Deutschlands zähle.
Moin, Leute.
Dem wären sich
viele gerne bewusst, oder?
Wärt ihr euch nicht auch gerne bewusst, dass ihr
zu den Topverdienenden in Deutschland gehört?
Ich bin Yashi, 28 Jahre alt
und arbeite als Customer Success Manager
in Berlin.
Berlin, okay.
Der Nachteil an Berlin ist Berlin.
Was hast du da in der Mitte?
Dann nehme ich davon einfach eine Hälfte.
Danke euch, schönen Tag noch.
Ich fange normalerweise um neun an,
manchmal sogar einen Tick später.
Erstmal gechillt die Jogginghose.
Das finde ich super, ich bin nämlich langschläfig.
Genau so würde ich es auch machen.
Das macht ihn mir schon mal sehr sympathisch,
dass er nicht auch als Customer Success Manager
im Homeoffice im Anzug hockt.
Es könnte natürlich sein,
dass er sich noch obenrum
ordentlich was anziehen muss
für irgendwelche Meetings, aber mal gucken.
Also ich mag das
von zu Hause arbeiten eigentlich total,
weil ich habe relativ starkes ADHS,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwo bin in einem Office
und dann acht Stunden mit Kunden telefoniere,
gehe ich wahrscheinlich auch dann den
den Mitmenschen ein bisschen auf den Lecker.
Auf den Sack.
Layover Lowes, ne?
Mein Job ist es, dass ich Startups beibringe,
wie sie Kundensupport-Software nutzen.
Kundensupport-Software nutzt du jeden Tag,
ohne es zu wissen, für jeder...
Moment, dafür muss man gecoacht werden?
Das siehst du mal, was es nicht alles gibt.
...eine einzelne Retoure,
für jede Kontaktaufnahme,
mit jetzt irgendeinem Business.
Kurzer Check, dass alles läuft.
Und das können sich Startups leisten.
Startups haben doch eigentlich kein Geld.
Startups machen doch...
Bei Startups ist doch das Wichtigste,
dass das Mindset stimmt, Leute.
Das Mindset und die Vision.
Oder was erzählen sie dir immer?
24-7 arbeiten.
Wenn sich die Kopfhörer wieder nicht verbinden würden,
das ist immer das Beste.
Tja.
Hätte man halt ein gescheites Headset
und ein gescheites Audio-Interface,
dann würde ich sagen,
Olga, kannst du mich hören?
Ich kann dich nicht hören. Test, Test, Test.
Olga!
Ja, ich kann dich hören. Perfekt.
Mein Arbeitsbereich ist Europa,
mittlere Osten und Afrika.
Sprich, mein Kunde kann aus London kommen,
aber er kann auch aus Südafrika kommen.
Sie sagte zu Beginn, dass du ein paar Probleme hast.
Es sollte nicht der Fall sein,
dass du normalerweise keine Internet-Probenz hast
oder es funktioniert gut.
Es ist nur so, dass das Loaden nicht schnell genug ist.
Ich habe mir das gleiche Kappen von Amazon gekauft,
wie ich.
Das Original, die habe ich mir auch vor einem Jahr
oder so gekauft, weil meine andere den Geist aufgegeben hat.
Exakt die gleiche Kappe von Amazon.
The place where the server is,
is the problem
because it's just like too far away.
I'll have to check
with the solutions architect.
Moment.
Der Server ist too far away.
Ja gut, das kann durchaus sein.
Wenn die in Russland sitzen
und der Server steht in N.A. oder so,
und die werden über Frankfurt geroutet,
da kann es ein bisschen laggen.
Aber,
je nachdem, was die machen,
ist das...
Eine große Schwierigkeit
für vor allem meine Kunden,
weil es Startups sind,
ist, dass sie nicht wissen, wo sie anfangen sollen.
Das ist vollkommen fein.
Der verdient sein Geld damit,
dass er ganz nach auf Englisch redet.
So schlecht kann es nicht sein.
Sein Schreibtisch sieht noch besser aus als meiner.
Man kann ganz, ganz viel damit machen.
Und es ist so ein bisschen wie Lego.
Du kriegst nur leider
keine so gute Anleitung.
Da müssen wir vor allen Dingen dann ansetzen
und den Kunden an die Hand nehmen
und da durchleiten.
Erkennt man irgendwie,
was die da haben?
Erkennt man irgendwie, was das ist?
Ich hätte es ja erst mal gesagt,
links sieht ein bisschen aus wie Teams,
aber das ist nicht die Teams-Farbe.
Was ist denn das da unten?
Ist das Zendesk oder wie das heißt?
Das hat doch so ein komisches Z.
Das ist Zendesk, glaube ich, gell?
Also nicht Xen, sondern Zen.
Hat er gerade gesagt?
Ach so, okay.
Dann habe ich,
dann habe ich das komplett...
Ja, das ist Zendesk.
... seine ersten 10 Stunden mit Zendesk.
Äh, do you see like,
there's like three,
a little bit down,
to the...
Yeah, there we go.
Boah, da hätte ich ja
so keinen Bock drauf, Mann!
Alter,
wenigstens ein
richtiger Tab-Enjoyer,
damit kann ich mich auf jeden Fall,
das macht ihn mir sehr sympathisch,
der macht das richtig.
Ihr wisst ja, wie das ist.
Ist übrigens gar kein Mac.
Aber da hätte ich ja
so keinen Bock drauf.
Endkunden-Support im Endeffekt
und dann denen
zeigen müssen, wo sie klicken,
da raste ich aus bei.
Ach, du meinst, das ist Remote?
Dann ist der andere Typ nicer Tab-Enjoyer.
Dann mag ich den
auf der anderen Seite der Leitung.
Aber, oh, da hätte ich,
das wäre ja Horrorszenario für mich.
Ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen random Leuten
reden, die keine Ahnung haben
und dann ihnen zeigen, wo sie klicken müssen.
Ach, du Scheiße, Mann!
Im Prinzip ist das
ein Support-Mitarbeiter
mit einem coolen Namen.
Maybe, what happens if you click in
user, so you can just
like type in user
and then we see nothing, that's perfect.
Ich muss mal klug scheißen,
es ist kein Studio-Mikrofon
allein schon, weil es über USB geht.
Maybe it's request.
Wobei, geht das über USB?
Das hier sieht nicht,
das sieht eher von der Kabel-Dicke
eher nach einem XLR-Kabel aus, ja.
Dann vielleicht doch, dann vielleicht doch.
Can you type in requester?
There we go.
Thank you, bye bye.
Also der Call lief erstmal eigentlich
gut, der Erfolg
SM7B,
das ist doch das, was die irgendwie gefühlt
seit 100 Jahren verwenden, oder?
Der Erfolg
ist, dass die Kunden am Ende
nach dem Startup-Programm
Bock auf das Produkt, auf die Software
haben und das weiter nutzen und dafür bezahlen.
Ah, die haben, okay,
jetzt verstehe ich es, die schließen eine Trial
ab, in der Trial-
periode kümmert der sich drum,
dass das bei denen alles gut läuft
und nach der Trial-periode
werden sie erstmal richtig
zur Kasse gebeten. Das ist auch
ein gutes, ne, also
nach sechs Monaten Trial-periode,
wenn die dann so richtig abhängig sind von
dem Programm und sich dran gewöhnt haben
und auch denken, ey,
der Support ist ja richtig gut,
dann werden sie ins kalte Wasser geschmissen
und dann nach dem Motto, alter, jetzt
Kohle her.
Aber irgendwann muss die Kohle mal rumkommen, ja, schon verständlich.
Brauche ich dafür 10 Calls,
50 Calls oder irgendwas dazwischen,
ist am Ende komplett egal.
Es geht am Ende natürlich ums Geld,
dass der da rumkommt für die Firma.
Und dann geht es eigentlich auch direkt
weiter, weil in
21 Minuten, also 20 Minuten
und ein bisschen, fängt schon wieder der nächste
nächste Call an.
Hello, how are you doing?
Boah, da hätte ich so keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist für mich eines der, das wäre
eines der größten Abfuck-Jobs überhaupt.
Ich meine, immerhin, eine gute Sache ist,
du kannst das komplett remote machen, okay,
aber da hätte ich
so keinen Bock drauf, Alter.
Have a negative to know more
about your potential client. So
ask them about like, hey, how quickly
do you want to sell? Is there like a
prior on this? How much does it cost?
Yada, yada, yada, right? And then
we can just like go from there and collaborate again, right?
Thank you, bye bye.
Sie wollten diesen Call jetzt haben, weil sie
gemerkt haben, sie nutzen nicht das komplette Potenzial
der Software und deswegen
habe ich da jetzt nochmal ein bisschen
best practices
eben nicht beigebracht, aber einfach vermittelt
und das war perfekt.
Ist vermittelt nicht einfach
nur ein anderes Wort für beigebracht?
Oder beigebracht nicht nur ein anderes Wort für vermittelt?
Das war genau so, wie es laufen
muss.
Lunch?
Fooding?
I will go to
Sahara. Haloumi and Chicken,
yeah? Ja.
Würde ich jetzt auffordern.
Erdnuss und
Schaf, aber dann ein bisschen extra Joghurt.
Genau, einfach drauf. Super,
danke dir. Danke dir.
Schönen Tag euch, ciao, ciao. Ah, die
Lieferandotüte. Willst du was gucken oder nicht?
Was denn?
Was ist denn so eine Frage?
Wann haben wir jemals etwas anderes geguckt?
Okay.
Okay, dann
scheint es ja gut zu gehen.
Die Wohnung ist echt klein für zwei
Leute, oder?
Cringe.
Ich wohne relativ
Ich, also es kann ja jeder
machen, wie er will, aber mir
wäre das viel zu sehr auf die Pelle gerückt.
Das ist alles günstig und
ich habe einfach sehr viel Glück gehabt,
weil das ist die Wohnung von meiner Freundin
und ich war damals auch auf
einer Wohnungssuche und sie hat dann
gesagt, hey, deine Wohnungssuche ist super
unerfolgreich, du kriegst gar nicht gebacken,
willst du bei mir einziehen? Habe ich
irgendwelche Versicherungen? Haftpflicht. Haftpflicht.
Perfekt, super. Also keine Hausreitung, gar nichts.
Ja, als nächstes
wühle ich mich weiter durch E-Mails.
Wie man hier sieht, ich habe hier noch einen ganzen
Batzen offen. Ich würde da auch Zustände
kriegen, wenn man sich den ganzen Tag sieht. Also
ihr wisst, er kann ja
offensichtlich besser mit anderen Leuten,
weil sonst wäre
kein Customer Success Manager den ganzen Tag
mit Leuten redet.
Ich würde durchdrehen.
Den ganzen Tag
da zusammen in der Wohnung und
auf so engem Raum.
Ich wäre da durchgedreht.
Also jetzt ungefähr
liegen wir hier bei 90 E-Mails. Klar, das ist
jetzt nicht so spannend, wie irgendwie
90?
Das macht unser
Monitoringsystem in einer Viertelstunde.
90 E-Mails ist
ja nichts.
Ich bin trotzdem part of the job.
Also Motivationsprobleme bei den E-Mails,
ich glaube, das hat jeder irgendwann mal.
Klub Marte hilft. Und am Ende heißt es dann
einfach Augen zu und durch.
Brutto pro Monat bekomme ich
7.250 Euro.
Da geht schon was.
Das heißt am Ende auf meinem Bankaccount.
Aber da zählt wahrscheinlich
auch nochmal ganz stark dazu, wie gut
er Leute eben,
wie soll man sagen, in
Bezahlabos bringt. Ich denke mal,
die werden ihm nicht einfach random,
das bezahlen,
sondern da ist sicherlich auch gewisse
Erfolgswerte dran geknüpft.
Der muss die beantworten und nicht löschen.
Ja, das ist natürlich wieder, da hast du recht.
Da hast du recht.
Das ist natürlich 90 E-Mails, wo man auch was
drauf schreiben muss. Aber dank ChatGPT
geht das auch heutzutage besser.
Das ist doch schon mal ordentlicher Betrag.
Das sind dann 4.266 Euro.
Ich bin mir dessen bewusst, dass ich
in meinem Gehalt zu den Topverdienenden
in Deutschland zähle. Andererseits
zeigt es mir aber auch, dass ganz ganz viele Menschen
mit wichtigeren Jobs zu wenig verdienen.
J-J-J-Japan
denke ich auch, dass der auf jeden Fall
gewisse Erfolgszahlen
vorweisen muss. Vermutlich wäre mein Gehalt
ein bisschen niedriger, wenn ich bei einer deutschen Firma
arbeiten würde. Wahrscheinlich. Allerdings
habe ich mittlerweile auch Angebote von deutschen
Firmen bekommen, die
in dem gleichen Gehalt sind. Ja gut, ich meine,
die müssen ja. Das ist halt so eines dieser Dinger,
was auch noch reinspielt, wenn es ums
Thema Fachkräftemangel geht. Da hatten wir es ja
letztens mit diesem Heise-Artikel und diesem
anderen PDF dafür.
Die Leute können halt auch
heutzutage
international suchen, wenn es sich um
reine Homeoffice-Beträge
handelt.
Das kommt jetzt noch dabei. Das heißt,
die Firmen können sich das sogar doppelt
nicht leisten, ihre
ach, es müssen jetzt alle wieder 100%
zurück ins Office-Pläne.
Ich meine, das können die zwar
probieren, aber es
beißt sich halt damit. Auf der einen
Seite sagen sie, oh, wir finden
keine Leute, unsere Stelle bleiben
offen, aber den Leuten ordentlich
was bezahlen und ihnen Homeoffice-
Möglichkeiten bieten, also sprich,
die Top, die absoluten Top-Punkte
dessen, was Leute wollen,
gerade in der IT, bieten
wir nicht. Ja, dann muss man sich nicht wundern,
wenn die Leute nicht zu einem gehen.
Ich verstehe diese Logik dahinter
nicht so. Wir machen nicht das,
was wir machen, also wir machen offensichtlich
nicht das, was wir machen müssen,
um Leute zu bekommen, aber
wir beschweren uns darüber, dass wir keine Leute
bekommen.
Ja.
Sehr gute.
Gute Idee.
Was hat er denn?
Was hat er denn? Aha.
E-Bike-Leasing.
E-Bike-Keg-Weight.
Oh nein, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Ähm, sieht man jetzt nicht mehr so doll,
weil ich jetzt seit Januar schon 12 Kilo abgenommen
habe, aber ich möchte auf jeden Fall...
Bin ich der Einzige, der während
Corona abgenommen hat?
Alle sind sie nur dicker geworden.
Ich habe in den zwei Jahren abgenommen 18 Kilo.
Das ist einer der Hauptgründe, warum wir da jetzt reingehen
und hoffentlich schwitzen.
Alles gut?
Sehr gut. Personal Trainer. Ganz
ehrlich, mit der Kohle, wenn es einem wichtig
ist, da Progress zu machen, kann man sich
das gönnen. Ich meine, warum nicht?
Irgendwo muss das Geld hin.
So.
Ich habe mir das auch schon überlegt, sollte
ich mal irgendwann ins Fitnessstudio gehen, also
ich stelle mir nicht die ganze Zeit jemand
nebendran oder so, aber einem,
der einem da... Ich meine, ich habe ja gar keine Ahnung,
wie man da richtig trainiert und auf was man achten
muss und sowas. Sollte ich das machen,
da werde ich mir auch die erste
Zeit mal irgendjemand gönnen, der mir da
das ein bisschen erklärt.
Aber aktuell habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock, ins Fitnessstudio
zu gehen. Ich bin mit meiner Ausdauergeschichte,
was Rennen und Fahrradfahren angeht,
soweit glücklich,
sollte es mir irgendwie mal nach
noch mehr Muskeln sein,
dann, ja, mache ich das
vielleicht auch.
Es ist außerdem nur eine Stunde Personal Training pro
Woche, kann man sich doch easy leisten.
Also
mit so einem Gehalt würde ich es auch machen.
Deswegen
wie immer mit Anleitung und
mit extra Motivation.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Ausgabe,
es ist aber eine Investition
in einen selber. Das beste Geld, was ich ausgeben
habe, mit Abstand. Eine Kleidung,
all die Gadgets, alles, was ich
irgendwann mal gekauft habe, selbst im Urlaub.
Ich kann die nächsten Urlaube nur machen,
wenn es mir körperlich gut geht.
Und muss ich halt jetzt anfangen.
Das ist so.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Und früher oder später
merkt man es halt. Gerade wenn man
mal so 30, 30 plus ist,
sag ich mal, da fängt es ja bei vielen an.
Gerade wenn ihr das so gemacht habt, wie ich.
Also quasi
schon immer viel vom,
ich habe ja nicht schon immer, muss man ja sagen.
Ich habe nicht schon immer viel vom Computer gehängt.
Früher, wo ich noch ein bisschen kleiner
war, da
gab es noch nicht so viele Computer daheim.
Ich meine, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das heißt so im Alter von
ich weiß nicht, wann habe ich,
wann haben wir den ersten PC gekauft?
1994 rum oder so.
94, 95 so in dem Dreh
würde ich vermuten.
Ja, so irgendwie.
Oder 94 vielleicht
10, 11 oder so bin ich da gewesen.
Und ab da ging es bergab.
Davor war ich noch
viel draußen, habe mit irgendwelchen
Leuten aus der Schule was gemacht.
War auch teilweise
mit Freunden aus der Schule
im Sommerurlaub auf irgendeinem Campingplatz
und sowas. Ich hatte damals aber auch
noch wenig Bock auf sowas.
Zumindest danach, als
ich dann Computer daheim hatte,
dann ging die ganze Sache bergab, Alter.
Dann habe ich
so viel angefangen mit Technik zu basteln.
Damals war ja mit Internet noch nichts.
Spätestens zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo es dann die Möglichkeit gab,
daheim ins Internet zu gehen.
Am Anfang mit Modem, teilweise ISDN,
später dann mit DSL. Ich meine, ich hatte
in Hanau einen der ersten DSL-Anschlüsse
der Welt, ne der Welt ist falsch, also
in Hanau einen der ersten
DSL-Anschlüsse ever,
die es gab. Und die Telekom hat es
damals schon nicht richtig hinbekommen.
Wir hatten mittlerweile sogar die Durch-,
beziehungsweise mein Vater ist denen so auf den Sack gegangen,
der hatte mittlerweile sogar die Durchwahl
zum hessischen Telekom-Chef.
Naja.
Andere Story.
Zumindest ab da ging es dann bergab.
Ab dann habe ich nur noch vor dem Computer gehockt den ganzen Tag.
Und wenn ihr das dann so lange macht wie ich,
ich habe es ja glücklicherweise noch nicht mein ganzes
Leben lang gemacht. Heute gibt es ja Leute, die machen das
ihr ganzes Leben lang. Sind auch teilweise schon
ihr ganzes Leben lang zu dick und sowas.
Bei mir ging es dann quasi erst so richtig
mit rumgehocke los,
als ich Internet am Start
hatte.
Und so richtig los ging es bei mir eigentlich
erst dann mit der Ausbildung,
wo ich dann
auf der Arbeit vor dem Rechner gesessen
habe, mich nicht mal bewegt habe
und gefressen habe.
Und abends auch noch
und am Wochenende auch noch
vor dem Rechner gesessen habe den ganzen
Tag und
gefressen habe und mich nicht
bewegt habe. Und
irgendwann, bei mir halt ein bisschen später,
weil ich war, sagen wir mal so, zumindest so die ersten
12, 13, 14
Jahre meines Lebens noch recht normal war,
ähm, habe ich vielleicht
erst ein bisschen später gemerkt, aber so
ab 30 habe ich
angefangen zu merken, dass das echt
auf Dauer auch nicht so geil ist.
Da hast du, du hast öfters Kopfweh,
du hast wassig Verspannungen,
dir tut der Arsch weh,
ja, Gachi Bass,
ähm, du hast irgendwelche Probleme
am Hintern, dass es beim Laufen
dann zieht bis in die Beine, also ganz ganz
ekliges Zeug. Und
irgendwann, nachdem ich mir das, also ich habe
ja erst gar nicht daran gedacht, ich meine eigentlich auch richtig
dumm von mir gewesen, ne, ich habe erst gar nicht
daran gedacht, dass es daran liegt, dass ich den ganzen Tag
vorm Rechner sitze. Ich meine,
wie könnte, wie könnte es auch nur daran liegen,
dass man den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzt?
Ich dachte, ich dachte erst so irgendwie,
so keine Ahnung, ich bin dann zum,
zum Arzt gegangen und sonst
wie und habe gesagt, oh, ich habe hier so Probleme
und sonst, die haben natürlich auch gesagt, ja,
sitzen sie viel vorm Rechner, aber ich habe immer nicht
daran gedacht, dass es daran liegt, dass man
vorm Rechner sitzt. Ich habe halt gedacht,
ich habe irgendwas, so irgendwie Muskelprobleme
oder so. Ja, ich hatte, ich habe
gerade was, ich hatte einfach viel zu wenig
Bewegung, ne,
und dann habe ich irgendwann noch, und
also, wo ich, wo ich
echt angefangen habe, mir ein bisschen,
bisschen Gedanken zu machen ist,
hattet ihr schon mal doppelte Herzschläge?
Hat jemand schon mal
doppelte Herzschläge?
Und weiß, wie sich das anfühlt?
Ja, das fühlt sich ganz furchtbar
weird an, wenn ihr doppelte Herzschläge habt.
Das kommt übrigens auch oftmals durch zu wenig Bewegung.
Das fühlt sich ungefähr
so an, überleg,
stellt euch vor, stellt euch vor,
ich habe jetzt ein ganz gutes Beispiel für,
stellt euch vor, ihr lauft
auf dem Gehweg
an einem Tor
vorbei,
und hinter dem Tor
sind zwei Hunde, die gegen das Tor
springen und euch erschrecken.
Also, hat wahrscheinlich
jeder schon mal erlebt, ihr ahnt
nichts Böses,
ihr lauft an einem Tor vorbei, und auf einmal
denkst du, du wirst gleich gefressen
von der Seite. Du hast Hunde, die
bellen übelst laut von jetzt auf gleich, springen
gegen das Tor, und du erschreckst dich.
So.
Du erschreckst dich nicht in Form von
Alter, ich
irgendwie
da steht einer mit einer Pistole
vor mir oder so, sondern du erschreckst
dich halt durchs Laut, und weil es halt
gefährlich ist, und du es nicht einschätzen kannst, und nicht erst
mal realisierst, dass da noch ein Tor dazwischen ist,
aber dann ist relativ schnell auch wieder gut.
Du machst, hä?
Du merkst dich, merkst du richtig, dass du
bisschen Adrenalin im Kreislauf
hast, guckst nach links,
stellst fest, ach, das sind ja nur,
das sind ja nur, das sind ja nur Hunde hinterm Tor,
und dann beruhigst du dich relativ schnell wieder.
Ungefähr so,
bloß nicht ganz so krass,
fühlen sich doppelte Herzschläge an.
Das ist ganz eklig, das ist ganz eklig.
Ja.
Und, also es ist wirklich
nichts, was man haben will.
Es ist auch nichts Schlimmes, man stirbt nicht.
Aber es ist halt ein bisschen eklig.
Und es ist wirklich richtig
aberlich. Zumindest,
das hatte ich, und da war ich
beim Hausarzt, der hat es
erst nicht gecheckt, und irgendwann hat er es dann auch
festgestellt, dann war ich beim Kardiologe,
und die haben das, so,
und die haben dann gesagt, ach,
Herr Marx, das ist nicht schlimm, da
passiert Ihnen nichts von,
dann bewegen Sie sich mal mehr. Und da habe ich mir
auch gedacht, jaja, ihr labert immer einen Scheiß,
was soll das mit mehr bewegen, das hat
doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das hat doch
damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas, und
ihr habt bloß keinen Bock zu gucken.
Das kann doch jetzt nicht von jetzt auf gleich
einfach am Bewegen liegen.
Ich habe mir dann echt eingeredet,
das liegt nicht am zu wenig bewegen.
Und ich habe dann
ab und zu gedacht, okay,
okay, was ist, wenn die doch recht haben?
Was ist, wenn die doch recht haben, und es liegt
am zu wenig bewegen? Dann bin ich halt,
dann bin ich halt mal hier,
halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten so,
um Block gelaufen,
und dann habe ich dann festgestellt, ah, ist immer noch da,
ist überhaupt kein Ding, also muss ich mich auch nicht
mehr bewegen. Geile Schlussfolgerung, oder?
Eins, zwei,
eins, zweimal langsam ums Haus
gelaufen für eine halbe Stunde, und danach
gehofft, es ist alles weg, es war nicht alles weg,
und natürlich hatten die alle
Unrecht, und Bewegung
bringt nichts, so. So, und das habe ich
dann noch ein bisschen so weitergemacht,
bis ich dann irgendwann, ich weiß
gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, warum
ich damit angefangen habe, ja,
irgendwann habe ich gesagt, okay,
ich hätte
mal Bock drauf,
ich hätte mal Bock drauf,
mir ein bisschen
die umliegende Landschaft hier anzugucken.
Und ich bin schon immer ganz
gerne wandern gegangen dort, also
gerade auch früher, dort, also
damals noch mit Eltern und
allen anderen,
dort, wo es ein bisschen hügelig ist,
ja, und wir haben ja den Spessart hier um die Ecke,
Taunus um die Ecke und so, und da bin ich
dann irgendwann mal hier, nicht weit weg,
halbe Stunde weg,
zu einem Berg gefahren,
der ist, was, 380
Meter oder sowas, das zählt wahrscheinlich in Österreich,
in der Schweiz auch nicht als Berg,
380 Meter, und bin da ein bisschen rumgelaufen,
so für eine Stunde,
was übelst anstrengend für mich gewesen
ist,
und das hat mir gefallen, ja,
das hat mir gefallen, und
ab dem Zeitpunkt bin ich dann
immer regelmäßiger,
ganz normal, ohne jetzt irgendwie
super krasse Fitness-Scheiß machen zu wollen,
rausgegangen
und bin einfach
spazieren gegangen am Anfang,
so, und irgendwann habe ich festgestellt,
ey, das ist,
Moin Nilsson, das ist
gar nicht so übel, ja, wenn man sich ein bisschen
bewegt, das ist gar nicht so schlecht,
und das hat sich dann immer weiter gesteigert,
bis ich irgendwann
tatsächlich jeden Tag,
außer meistens sonntags, weil sonntags hier
im Streaming, jeden Tag
mindestens eineinhalb Stunden
ganz normal,
und dann auch immer schneller, ja,
hier durch die Landschaft gelaufen
bin, und seitdem ich das mache, und das ist jetzt auch
schon einige Jahre her, ich meine, ich bin,
das habe ich so mit 30 gemerkt,
und, ähm,
jetzt bin ich fast 40,
das mache ich jetzt schon ein paar Jahre,
und dann habe ich irgendwann
festgestellt, okay,
das wird ja immer besser,
und jetzt habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mehr,
ich habe viel weniger
Kopfschmerzen, keine Verspannung mehr,
beim Laufen Probleme, keine doppelten
Herzschläge mehr und nichts, und da dachte ich mir so,
okay, irgendwie
scheinen
die Ärzte doch zu wissen, wovon sie
geredet haben, mehr Bewegung bringt was,
und ich habe wirklich nichts Tolles
gemacht, ich bin einfach nur,
ja, man muss nicht so viel laufen, aber ich habe da
mittler, ich habe da wirklich
zwischenzeitlich, ähm,
zwischenzeitlich meinen Gefallen dran gefunden,
und wenn ich nicht mindestens jeden Tag
Sonntags mal außen vor, Sonntags ist es
nur ab und zu mal, aber wenn ich nicht
mindestens
jeden Tag eineinhalb Stunden
rumgelaufen bin,
fehlt mir was, so,
und jetzt wird es sogar noch extremer,
jetzt habe ich ja noch
Rennen und Fahrradfahren für mich entdeckt,
sodass ich jeden zweiten Tag
zusätzlich noch, kommt noch dabei,
dass ich jeden zweiten Tag zusätzlich
noch meine
fünf, also ich habe, ich habe drei,
ich habe vier Strecken, ich habe vier Strecken, die ich
hier renne, eine ist exakt
fünf Kilometer, die ist auch
so gut wie es geht flach,
die benutze ich immer, wenn ich, wenn ich mal
so schnell rennen will, wie irgendwie geht,
fünf Kilometer, dann ist meine normale
Strecke, ist
6,2 Kilometer,
dann habe ich eine lange Strecke,
die so einmal über ein paar Brücken meint,
die ist 10,2
Kilometer, und dann
kann ich noch eine Rennen mit ein bisschen
Schlenker zu dieser 10,2 Kilometer
Strecke, dann ist sie 11,2 Kilometer,
so,
und
die renne ich halt abwechselnd,
je nachdem, wie es mir
danach ist, wie das Wetter so ist,
meistens mache ich so, dass ich
sonntags morgens die lange Strecke renne,
deswegen sind meine Streams in letzter Zeit auch immer
ein bisschen später, sonntags morgens,
und
also ich habe jetzt, weg Alu,
weg, also ich habe
jetzt, ja das ist
mein aktueller Rekord über fünf Kilometer,
jetzt habe ich irgendwas gepostet,
hab,
ja, ach die 11 habe ich noch gar nicht
gepostet, also das ist, das ist so
ungefähr das, was ich, was ich
bei 10 Kilometer auf die Reihe kriege, aktuell,
also 10 Kilometer brauche ich
knapp eine Stunde für,
brauche ich knapp eine Stunde für, aber wie gesagt,
heute war ich nicht, also 10 Kilometer brauche ich
mittlerweile knapp eine Stunde für, und renne
pro Kilometer das in
6 Minuten 22, 6 Minuten 22
pro Kilometer ist
nicht entspannt,
aber gut, gut drinne,
aktuell, also ich kann, ich kann
ungefähr so,
wenn ich es ganz übertreibe,
knapp eine Minute schneller rennen,
aber dann packe ich da noch keine 10 Kilometer,
ja,
so, und das mache ich jetzt seit August,
zusätzlich,
habe ich ja noch angefangen,
dann,
Ende, Ende des Sommers noch
mir ein Fahrrad zu kaufen,
ich hatte so ein Fahrrad hier, was ist denn das,
warte hier,
das hier,
gibt es das wieder, ausverkauft,
vielleicht in blau, äh in grün,
ausverkauft,
also das hier,
hatte ich mir gekauft,
und bin damit auch gefahren,
hat mega Bock gemacht,
bis ich dann,
ich glaube es ist Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad,
umgefahren wurde,
an der Ausfahrt
von einem Auto,
wohlgemerkt, ich bin auf einem
Fahrradweg gefahren,
die hatte komplett Vorfahrt achten,
und ich komplett Vorfahren in alle
Richtungen, also,
ja, da habe ich mich halt umgefahren,
so, und jetzt ist mein Fahrrad kaputt,
zumindest soweit kaputt,
dass ich nicht
mehr draußen fahren kann,
weil das ist ein Carbonrahmen,
das heißt, da weißt du nicht, ob es irgendwelche Mikrorisse hat,
und die Versicherung hat immer noch
nicht bezahlt, aber die Versicherung hat es schon akzeptiert,
und überweist
dann irgendwann, wenn sie will, so,
keine Ahnung, zum Glück habe ich das
beim Anwalt, und habe mich da nicht selbst
drum gekümmert,
also,
und jetzt habe ich das Fahrrad hier hinter mir auf einem
Smart Trainer von Wahoo
stehen, auf einem Wahoo
Kicker Core,
und fahre da alle paar Tage
meine Stunde auf dem Fahrrad,
ich time es meistens so,
also ich versuche es meistens so
zu timen,
dass ich
renne, Fahrrad fahre,
Pause mache,
sodass ich
quasi
möglichst viel Zeit habe,
meine
Schienbeine so ein bisschen zu schonen
vom Rennen, und trotzdem
alle zwei bis drei Tage rennen kann,
das muss ich dann immer so, das läuft dann entweder
drauf raus auf Rennen, Fahrrad fahren,
Pause, oder
manchmal,
wenn ich ganz hart drauf bin, ist es
auch Rennen, Fahrrad fahren,
Pause,
den Tag danach,
so in der Richtung, ja, läuft es da meistens
drauf raus, dass ich alle zwei bis drei Tage rennen kann,
und zwischendurch mal dann
am Tag, wo ich nicht renne, Fahrrad fahre,
manchmal mache ich auch keine Pause,
mache ich einen Tag vorher Pause fahren, dann Fahrrad,
einen Tag rennen, zumindest so, dass ich
1 bis 2 Tage immer
ein bisschen Entspannung für die Beine habe,
also für das Schienbein habe,
weil beim Rennen geht es mir hauptsächlich
aufs Schienbein, das Wasser wahrscheinlich auch daran,
liegt, dass ich immer noch um die 90 Kilo wiege,
ja, so, soweit dazu,
und funktioniert die Schaltung noch,
die Schaltung war verbogen,
nach dem Unfall, nach dem Unfall war die
Schaltung verbogen, aber was ich
gemacht habe, ist, ich habe mir bei Rose
ein, ähm, ein
Schaltauge gekauft, ich wusste gar nicht, dass
es sowas gibt,
ich habe mir bei Rose das passende
Schaltauge gekauft, das ist das, woran die
Schaltung aufgehängt wird, am Rahmen,
und das ist dafür gemacht, dass bevor sich die
Schaltung verbiegt, sich zuerst das hier verbiegt,
und das hat tatsächlich auch funktioniert,
denn es war nur, oder fast,
fast nur, weil die Schaltung dann immer noch
kratzer und nicht so hundertprozentig mehr intakt,
aber geht noch, ähm,
habe ich mir für 14 Euro so ein Ding gekauft,
habe das ausgetauscht,
Monkess, und
jetzt geht die Schaltung wieder, ich, ich
müsste nochmal ein bisschen mehr feinjustieren wieder,
weil bei manchen Gängen,
da würde ich es noch ein bisschen schleifen,
aber im Großen und Ganzen
funktioniert es auf dem Heimtrainer, auf die
Straße würde ich mich damit nicht trauen,
weil man weiß ja echt nie, ob der Carbonrahmen
was abgekriegt hat, zumindest
so sieht es aktuell aus,
und wie kommt man da auf 3400 Euro?
Das ist ganz einfach, wie man da auf 3400 Euro kommt,
nämlich,
indem man, indem man
einen kompletten Carbonrahmen hat,
Carbonlenker,
elektronische Schaltung,
1x11, wobei ich, wenn ich mir ein neues
Fahrrad kaufe, ich hoffe ja drauf,
dass die nächstes Jahr
1x12 elektronisch
releasen,
die Räder sind auch nicht billig,
und das alles in Kombination,
kostet halt was,
Powermeter, ne noch nicht,
aktuell habe ich halt das Powermeter aus dem Smarttrainer,
am Fahrrad selbst,
bin ich mir noch unschlüssig, am neuen Fahrrad werde ich
dann entweder, ja,
aber, ich wollte mir auch
erst SRAM holen,
wobei ich immer noch nicht weiß, ob man die SRAM oder
SRAM ausspricht, ich glaube mir natürlich die SRAM aus,
wollte ich mir auch tatsächlich erst
holen, aber ich habe mir mal die Unterschiede
angeguckt, also, ich finde die Art und
Weise, wie man schaltet, dort nicht so intuitiv,
und außerdem, und das finde ich echt doof, dass es
das nicht gibt, haben die keine Knöpfe
oben dran, wo man seinen Fahrradcomputer mitsteuern
kann, das finde ich ja mega an dem
Shimano Ding, dass du oben noch so
zwei Knöpfe hast, wo du beispielsweise
vom Lenker die Screens
an deinem Fahrradcomputer durch,
durchskippen kannst,
zumindest, da kommst du relativ schnell
auf die Kohle, gar nicht,
oder vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn ich
eine schöne Strecke gefunden habe, 20km,
hast du dadurch abgenommen? Ja,
habe ich, ich habe abgenommen von
108 auf jetzt knapp 90 Kilo,
wobei ich die letzten,
die letzten drei, vier Kilo, oder sagen wir die
letzten drei Kilo, die habe ich
tatsächlich jetzt erst abgenommen, seit ich
angefangen habe, August
noch mehr Sport zu machen.
Dürfen sie nicht, na, Shimano wird ja bestimmt nicht
das Patent auf Buttons haben,
na, dann müssen sie es halt irgendwie anders machen,
zumal SRAM ja sogar extra Buttons hat,
die du an
dein Lenker
schnappen kannst, aber mit denen kannst du
nicht den Fahrradcomputer steuern,
obwohl sie ein eigenes
Funksystem haben, sie verwenden ja nicht
dieses DI2 Zeug
da von Shimano, sie haben ja was eigenes,
sie haben ja so ein Open Source Bluetooth
Ding sich ausgedacht, sie könnten das schon
machen, aber machen sie nicht, was ich doof finde.
Gut, soweit,
soweit so gut, ja, und deswegen,
ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir da jetzt drauf gekommen sind,
aber, um, um das Ganze, um das Ganze
nochmal abzuschließen, Leute,
ich habe selbst eine ganze Weile für gebraucht,
bis ich das gecheckt habe,
aber gerade, wenn man den ganzen Tag vorm Computer sitzt,
ein bisschen Bewegung
ist nicht verkehrt,
deswegen kann ich das voll und ganz nachvollziehen,
hier im Video, dass sich das für ihn lohnt,
dort regelmäßig mit einem Trainer
zu schwitzen.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, 1,2000
Euro Free, Free, Free,
Freezeit, Freezeit und Lifestyle,
geht schon,
geht schon ordentlich was raus, 600 Euro
Essen, na gut, Essen ist teuer geworden,
das ist halt ein Vorteil, den ich habe,
muss ich, muss ich jetzt mal, muss ich jetzt mal sagen,
ich bin äußerst genügsam,
was das angeht, ich kau-,
ich gebe so gut wie nix
für sinnlosen Scheiß aus, ja,
oder, was ich für sinnlosen Scheiß halte,
die meisten Leute halten das ja nicht für, nicht, nicht,
nicht für sinnlosen Scheiß, ja,
ich habe weder ein fettes Auto,
noch
gebe ich massig viel für Klamotten,
aus, noch brauche ich irgendwie
1000 neue Sachen,
also,
ich gebe kaum Geld aus,
und mir fehlt
auch, ehrlich gesagt, nix,
das einzige, was ich
mache ist, ich spende ab und zu mal was
ans Tierheim, letztens erst wieder,
also
letztens letzte Woche, ähm,
ich habe leider keine Fotos
gemacht, ich war jetzt zweimal im Tierheim,
die letzten paar Wochen,
und habe da ein bisschen Futter, noch Futter
Spende vorbeigebracht, und habe den auch nochmal
500 Euro überwiesen,
aber, ich wollte mal ein paar Fotos machen, habe ich mir
gedacht, können wir ein bisschen Fotos machen, und ein paar Fotos
auf Twitter posten, aber habe ich dann
irgendwie nicht mehr, habe ich irgendwie verdrängt,
war ich zu sehr damit beschäftigt,
wie legst du dein Geld an?
Ich
bin der noobigste, wo habe ich denn
mein Handy überhaupt?
Wolltest du hier gerade sagen,
ich habe einen World
Index ETF
Ding, äh, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie der genau heißt,
da kommt die ganze
Kohle rein, das ist so ziemlich
das langweiligste, was man machen kann,
wo habe ich denn mein Handy? Ich wollte nämlich
mal gerade gucken, es liegt bestimmt noch im Bad,
wartet mal Leute, ich hole das mal schnell,
so,
jetzt, ich habe es gefunden, es lag
noch im Bett, das Handy,
also ich habe einen, Achtung,
End
App,
Alter, die Stonks, die sind schon,
okay, letzte, letzten drei Tage
nicht mehr so, aber die Stonks sind schon
massive raufgegangen dieses
Jahr, ey, also
eigentlich sind die so erst so richtig seit Oktober
raufgegangen,
also ich habe ein, wo steht's,
wo steht's,
ja, ich habe ein
Vanguard
FTSE All World
UCITS
ETF Accumulating,
was so viel heißt, wie
die Kohle, die man damit macht, wird wieder
reingesteckt, so,
das ist so ziemlich das langweiligste,
was man machen kann an Stonks,
aber irgendwie,
äh,
irgendwas, einfach nur auf dem Konto liegen
lassen, ist ja auch doof,
so, jetzt gucken wir mal,
wie es bei ihm aussieht,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Überschuss,
ja gut, wenn du mit so viel Geld keinen
Überschuss hast, dann weiß ich auch nicht,
also, was ich jetzt gelernt habe, ist,
was ich jetzt gelernt habe, ist,
er macht
Online-Support
für irgendeine
Helpdesk-Software,
das verdient eine Online, Moment,
die hatten wir schon, die hatten wir schon,
hast du ein,
hast du einen Steuerfreibetrag
für die Vorabpauschale schon eingestellt?
Nö,
ist das was, was ich, ist das was,
was ich machen muss, oder was mein Steuerberater macht?
Also, ich habe ja einen
Steuerberater genau aus dem Grund, weil ich
keinen Bock habe, mich um sowas zu kümmern.
Ich frage mich, wofür noch eine Ausbildungsstudie
lohnt sich kaum noch, das
würde ich nicht so sehen,
das war jetzt ein Beispiel,
bei dem das gut geklappt hat,
du wirst immer besonders
Ausreißer nach oben und
unten finden, überall, aber
man kann immer noch sagen, im Durchschnitt
fährst du mit einer Ausbildung
oder einem Studium auf jeden Fall besser
als ganz ohne. Wenn ich das
machen muss, wird mich da mein Steuerberater drauf
hinweisen, beziehungsweise hat er das schon für mich gemacht.
Aber ich habe doch gar keine Erträge.
Erträge habe ich doch erst, wenn ich
mir sie ausbezahlen lasse, oder?
Oder wollen die jetzt einfach schon Geld haben?
Moment, die wollen Geld haben für was, wovon
ich noch gar nichts habe, oder wie?
Langsam wird es aber auch abgedreht.
Mach Bitcoin.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wie jetzt,
nur mal, da ich das richtig verstehe,
aber ist gut, mein Steuerberater ist ja eh gerade
dabei, das alles zu machen für dieses
Jahr.
Ähm, nur weil ich das jetzt richtig
verstehe,
ich habe mein Geld in ETF gesteckt.
Heißt im Endeffekt, ich habe weder
Plus noch Minus gemacht zum aktuellen
Zeitpunkt, weil ich habe es ja
einfach nur gekauft.
So.
Auf was soll ich denn jetzt bitte schon Geld
bezahlen? Ich habe ja davon auch gar nichts.
Ich meine, ich könnte genauso gut weniger haben
am Ende.
Aber die Dividenden
gehen direkt wieder in ETF
rein. Wisst ihr,
ich weiß nicht,
um was es da jetzt...
Ah, geil.
Aber wie gesagt, mein Steuerberater
weiß das und dementsprechend
denke ich mal,
wird der mir das sagen, beziehungsweise
alles richtig machen. Dafür ist
er da.
Naja, also ein Ding ist halt, ich habe überhaupt
keine Probleme damit, Steuern zu bezahlen.
Ich würde
aber noch lieber Steuern bezahlen,
wenn ich das Gefühl hätte, dass
mit den Steuern was passiert, was
mir wichtig ist.
Der Jobmarkt ist momentan...
Du bist doch kein Junior
mehr, oder? Du bist schon Jahre hier im
Stream und hast Five Hat
Ideen. So neu kannst du doch gar nicht
sein. So,
also, wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben?
Was ist das? I'm done
with Windows. Tja, schön für ihn.
Das Problem ist,
leider kommen wir um Windows nicht so hundertprozentig
drum herum. Ich wäre der Erste,
der sagen würde, ey, 2000...
Leute, was meint ihr? 2024
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Genauso sicher wie alle
anderen Jahre davor das Jahr des Linux-Desktops
gewesen sind.
Also...
Warum geht KekG hier nicht?
Lasse, hören wir uns doch mal kurz an, was er
zu sagen hat.
Also, ich kann euch
sagen, warum ich Windows verwende.
Für Steuertricks
ApoRed fragen. Ja, er ist genau der Richtige,
wenn man den INSI-Modus richtig startet.
Wobei ApoRed uns ja auch letztens
erzählt hat, wie man der krasse Trader aus Dubai
wird. Der Trader-Hase läuft
halt. Wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, also der Grund, warum ich Windows verwende, ist
relativ einfach. Weil für mich
Gaming,
Streaming und Videoeditieren,
was ich für YouTube mache,
das traurige Ende
von Bibis Beauty... Stimmt!
Was ist eigentlich aus Bibi geworden?
Von der hat man ja ewig nichts mehr gehört, Mann!
Moment, da muss ich jetzt
gerade mal kurz gucken.
Naja, die hat immer noch gute Aufrufe.
Wo ist das Problem?
Die ist Mutter geworden, naja.
Mal gucken, wo man bleibt, oder?
Naja, zumindest zu der Windows-Geschichte zurück.
Weil es für meinen Anwendungszweck
was Streaming,
Videos und
Thumbnails und Spiele angeht, noch am
besten ist. Deswegen habe ich
einfach hier einen Linux laufen und da
einen Windows. Das ist für mich
die beste Kombination aus beidem.
Windows für das, wofür es gut ist,
Linux wofür es gut ist.
Und je nach Tagen bin ich 80%
in Linux und andere Tage bin ich 80%
in Windows. Was ist
Host-Windows? Weil sich Linux
unter Windows deutlich einfacher virtualisieren
lässt als Windows unter Linux.
Oder was heißt einfacher?
Besser! Virtualisieren lässt
als umgedreht. Und jetzt kommt
mir nicht mit der üblichen Sache,
die immer kommt im Chat. Max,
KVM-GPU-
Passthrough.
Ich habe keinen Bock immer wieder
das gleiche Thema zu haben und immer wieder das gleiche
darauf sagen zu müssen.
WSL. WSL fühlt sich
immer noch so fremdkörpermäßig für mich an.
Ich kann es nicht anders beschreiben.
WSL ist sicherlich ganz gut,
dass man jetzt wenigstens überhaupt
die Möglichkeit hat,
gescheit zu arbeiten unter Windows.
Wenn es denn Windows-only
sein muss. Aber es fühlt sich
immer noch so fremdkörpermäßig an.
Was ist deine Meinung zu C++?
Ich möchte das im
2024 anfangen zu lernen. Ja,
mach das. Fang an. C++.
Nur, dass Windows eigentlich nicht
gut für Gaming ist. Es ist nur die einzige
Option. Ja.
Sagen wir mal so.
Windows an sich,
nervt. Ja. Und nervt auch beim
Gaming. Aber Windows
ist...
Naja. Das ist ja so, wie wenn
ich sage, ähm...
Messer sind nicht gut
zum Schneiden. Das ist nur die einzige Option.
Wobei das ja nicht stimmt. Man könnte ja auch
eine Motorsäge oder so nehmen.
Das wäre dann ungefähr... Naja. Zumindest...
Windows hat
schon einige Vorteile
im Vergleich zu Linux,
was Gaming angeht. Klar,
das ist eher aus historischen Gründen
so gewachsen, dass das so ist.
Aber vergleicht mal den NVIDIA
Treiber Support für eine aktuelle NVIDIA Grafikkarte
unter Windows mit dem
von Linux.
Natürlich ist das
NVIDIA, die es verkacken. Ja, aber es ist halt
so. Das heißt, unterm Strich für uns
macht es keinen Unterschied. Man kann sich da jetzt lange
drüber streiten,
wo da die Probleme sind.
Aber letztendlich
unterm Strich für uns, wenn man es einfach nur
benutzen will, ist es halt einfach so.
Und das ist eine Sache, die unter Linux
auch so ein bisschen problematisch ist und warum es da oftmals
nicht so richtig vorwärts geht. Die brauchen
ewig sich
irgendwie den schwarzen Peter zuzuschieben.
Oh, ist das überhaupt noch korrekt, das
heute so zu nennen? Also sie brauchen
ewig sich den schwarzen Peter zuzuschieben.
Wer jetzt dafür zuständig ist?
Mein Lieblingsthema, ich will nicht wieder
davon anfangen, Recycle Story,
ja, ist
GPU-Decoding von Videos im Browser.
So, okay.
Weiter geht's.
Warum ist er denn jetzt
done mit Windows?
Ja, weil Windows abfuck hoch 10 ist.
Jedes Mal, ich mein,
wisst ihr, ich kann schon
nicht verstehen, warum man, also nicht,
dass man das jetzt täglich bräuchte, ja, ich kann schon nicht verstehen,
warum man so viele Rückschritte hat.
In Form von, man kann keinen, guck mal, sogar Windows ME
konnte man auf die Taskleiste ziehen.
Übrigens, was mir gerade auffällt,
mittlerweile sollte doch angeblich
auch entgruppieren funktionieren, oder?
Ich kann doch nicht entgruppieren.
Warum kann ich doch nicht entgruppieren, Leute?
Sollte das jetzt nicht gehen eigentlich?
Wo geht das? Ja.
Jawoll.
Sehr gut.
Übrigens, es gab auch mal Zeiten, da waren die
Dinger hier in ordentlicher Größe, aber naja.
So, endlich.
Endlich. Da war ich ja schon die ganze Zeit drauf.
Dass dieses dumme,
nervige Gruppieren weg ist.
So ist das. Ey, Leute,
das ist einfach so viel angenehmer,
Mann. Ich habe gar keine Ahnung, warum
das die ganze Zeit default ist.
Ja, Windows ist einfach
abfuck. Und was ich auch nicht verstehe,
ist, wenn man Windows 11
installiert, da muss man ja
während der Installation auswählen,
welches Tastatur-Layout
man haben will. Sobald die Installation
aber fertig ist, muss man das Tastatur-Layout
nochmal auswählen.
Und wenn man dann denkt, man könnte in dieser Liste
einfach G drücken für German
oder D für Deutsch, dass der
runterspringt zum deutschen Tastatur-Layout.
Nee, das geht da drinnen nicht.
Unter Windows ME ging das zum Beispiel
sogar. Das sind halt so Dinger, die
verstehe ich nicht. Was machen die bei Microsoft da?
So, also gucken wir uns das mal an.
Dann erzähl mal.
Debian.
Man kann auch, man kann auch
einfach Linux in der 4M
verwenden und Snapshots machen.
Ja, Windows ist komplett
unfähig, was das angeht. Es kommt ja auch
öfters vor, dass bei Windows-Updates
der Crap irgendwie kaputt ist. Das ist halt auch
Das ist, da kann mir keiner erzählen, dass
das keine Absicht ist.
Comax, danke für den Sub.
Das könnten die ohne Probleme machen.
Das checken.
Okay, wo ist jetzt das Problem?
Why it's annoying?
Ich, ich
Ich skippe mal kurz vor.
Okay, wo ist das?
Wo ist das?
Wo ist das Problem?
Okay, hier geht es eigentlich erst los.
Ja.
Oder, oder Apex, oder
irgendwas mit Anti-Cheat, was nicht Valve
Anti-Sheet ist.
This year in Destiny has been very dull in comparison to previous years.
In fact, I'm not even interested in playing the current season.
Going through the whole Windows installation process...
Hier, da hat man es gerade gesehen.
I'm not even interested in playing the current season.
Hier, in diesem Menü muss man dann nochmal das Tastatur-Layout auswählen.
Und hier kann man jetzt nicht einfach I drücken, um zu Irish zu springen oder sowas.
Das geht nicht.
Hat Microsoft sich gedacht, nein, das wollen wir nicht.
Das ging zwar vor 20 Jahren noch, aber jetzt geht es nicht mehr.
Stadia wurde schon vor zwei Jahren oder so geschlossen.
Ah, er hat eine AMD-Grafikkarte, deswegen klappt das unter Linux auch halbwegs.
Ja, da muss man echt sagen, das sind Dinger, die kriegt Nvidia besser hin.
Ich meine, ich verstehe es bei Nvidia auch bis heute nicht, warum man einen Account braucht,
um in seine Grafikkarten-Settings zu gehen.
Also, die normalen Settings, die gehen ja, aber die GeForce-Experience-Settings, die gehen nicht.
Da braucht man einen Account.
Wobei, und da frage ich mich seit Anfang an, warum zum Teufel brauche ich einen Account für irgendeinen Service
für meine fucking Grafikkarten-Settings?
Das konnte mir keiner erklären.
Nicht mal Nvidia konnte mir das erklären.
Keiner.
Das stimmt wohl.
Ja, das willst du jetzt nicht, weil du gerade kein Destiny spielen willst.
Aber warte mal ab, bis nächstes Jahr ein neues Destiny-Addon rauskommt und du wieder da spielen willst
und das nicht unter Linux funktioniert.
Das erste, was er macht ist, aha, lass uns mal wieder Windows installieren.
Ich mag Gnome nicht.
Psst, der scheiß Gnome.
Ich mag Gnome Desktop nicht.
Ich mag gar keine Linux-Desktops, das ist mein Problem.
Ich mag Windows Desktop auch nicht.
Das einzige, was ich mag, ist i3.
Okay, wahrscheinlich würde ich Sway auch mögen, wenn Wayland gescheit funktionieren würde.
Aber i3 ist das einzige, was ich mir geben kann.
Der Rest ist echt abfuck für mich.
Das muss man echt sagen.
Im professionellen Audio-Sort generell ist die letzten Jahre über etwas besser geworden.
Was ist mit anderen Tiling-VMs?
Da könnte ich mich damit auch anfreunden.
Ich habe Awesome eine Weile verwendet, könnte mich auch mit anfreunden.
Aber i3 geht mir einfach am wenigsten auf den Keks.
Es hat sich einiges getan.
Viele Audio-Bearbeitungssoftware gibt es unter Linux.
Es gibt DaVinci Resolve und solche Geschichten unter Linux.
Blender natürlich.
Es gibt mittlerweile immer mehr, was man unter Linux machen kann.
Mittlerweile ist glücklicherweise Microsoft Office oder so ein Krempel.
Gar kein richtiges Kriterium mehr für Linux, weil die meisten Leute verwenden es einfach im Browser und gut ist.
Es geht natürlich unter Linux auch.
Aber ansonsten, klar, es gibt immer noch genug, was nicht funktioniert an professioneller Software.
Beispielsweise aktuelles Creative Suite Photoshop oder sowas für Leute, die das brauchen,
was nur ein Bruchteil der Leute ist, die Photoshop nutzen.
Affinity läuft glaube ich auch nicht unter Linux gescheit.
Aber es wird tatsächlich.
Es wird tatsächlich ganz, ganz langsam etwas besser.
Sieht nicht mehr ganz so düster aus.
Wo es halt immer noch schwarz, wo es immer noch ganz, ganz schwarz aussieht, ist Anti-Cheat bei Spielen.
Weil, kannst du einfach vergessen.
Also wer Apex spielen will oder Rainbow Six oder CS geht mittlerweile.
Oder, ja, keine Ahnung.
Valorant.
Oder sowas.
Da hast du, da hast du gelitten, ja.
Wie sieht es eigentlich, eine Frage mal an euch chatten.
Wie sieht es, wie sieht es eigentlich mit League of Legends aus?
Weil Valorant läuft nicht richtig.
Echt?
Apex haben sie mittlerweile freigeschaltet, ja, dass das funktioniert.
Wie sieht das, wie sieht das, wie sieht das denn, wie sieht das mit, mit League of Legends aus aktuell?
Das ist ja auch Riot.
Exakt unter Linux, ja.
Also, es wird, es wird immer besser.
Ich bin der Erste, wenn, wenn es möglich ist, der Windows in die Tonne kloppt.
Lässiger Lord, da ist für den Zeitpunkt.
Windows Compatibility Layer Proton, which comes with Steam, has introduced many newcomers to Linux, maybe without them actually knowing.
Das stimmt.
Steam Deck, Arch by the way.
Linux is for everyone yet.
If you work for a company that wants or even pays you to use a certain application, then Linux is just not for you.
But what I am saying is, that Linux is ready to be used as a mainstream daily driver.
Das stimmt.
Heck, I myself...
Das, das ist richtig, das ist richtig halt, das habe ich ja auch in meinem Video dazu gesagt.
Das Video hieß sowas sinngemäß wie, äh, Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows oder sowas.
Habe ich ja da auch gesagt, wenn man mit allem auskommt und auch bereit ist, sich neue Sachen anzugucken, für manche, für, für Sachen, die man unter Windows, wenn es so nicht unter 1.13 Linux gibt, ist das vollkommen praxistauglich.
Wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann halt nicht.
Ja, es ist, man muss, man muss halt auch so sehen, wie es ist.
Es wird immer besser.
Aber gerade was das Thema Multiplayer-Spiele angeht und Anti-Cheat, da hast du halt immer noch so, höchstwahrscheinlich geht es nicht.
Du weißt nicht, was der nächste Patch bringt.
Und auch bei neuen Games ist es nicht so, dass du einfach braindead sagen kannst, Steam kaufen, runterladen, starten.
Vieles, ja, im Vergleich zu früher geht, ist halt nicht so.
Aber wenn man...
...mit allem klarkommt und alles hat unter Linux, was man braucht, oder mit dem, was man nicht hat, klarkommt, wenn man es, dass man es nicht mehr braucht, dann ist das vollkommen tauglich als Daily Driver.
...use it, and there are only two things that I needed to sacrifice.
For reconfiguring my mouse, instead of Logitech G-Hub, I use Solr.
And I can't play some games, which, besides Destiny 2, I never actually touched.
And that's it.
I've always been...
Nicht für dich.
Für viele andere ist das ein riesen Bestandteil dessen, warum sie ihren PC verwenden.
Gimp kann ich nicht leihen.
...and I can use Inkscape, if I wanted to draw something.
For recordings and editing, I use OBS and DaVinci Resolve.
Ja, DaVinci Resolve ist nice.
Just like I did on Windows.
When I play CS2, Minecraft, Apex Legends, GTA 5, or whatever.
Interessant, dass Apex mittlerweile gut funktioniert.
Nice.
...or else.
If it is with my friends, then I use Discord, which on KDE Plasma now also supports screen-sharing
on Wayland, if you use the ex-Wayland-Bridge.
Some distributions like Fedora already come with it pre-installed.
I'm not saying that everything was as easy as it is now.
Over more than one and a half years ago, I was not able to use the Flatpak version of
OBS, since it had green and purple artifacts in any recording.
Since I am on an AMD GPU now, I also cannot use the flatpak version of OBS.
Since I am on an AMD GPU now, I also cannot use the flatpak version of OBS, since it had
green and purple artifacts in any recording.
Since I am on an AMD GPU now, I also cannot use the flatpak version of OBS.
farming
Inflation
Leumble
Le PTS
Le pouvait
Inflation
Le pentru
Le opposed
Le Weighted
Le
Die können damit gar nichts anfangen. Die wissen gar nicht mal genau, was ihnen das Wort sagen soll. Nichtsdestotrotz, die meisten Omas und Opas und Eltern und so, die einfach nur einen Browser verwenden an einem Desktop-PC, die würden auch easy mit Linux höchstwahrscheinlich auskommen. Und es ist sogar besser, weil dann muss man sich nicht ständig Gedanken darüber machen, dass die sich irgendwo ein Virus einfangen.
Nein, ist es nicht. Das ist Windows-User-Geschwätz. Das ist Windows-User-Geschwätz, was ich denen noch nicht mal übel nehmen kann, weil wenn Windows-Leute an CLI und Terminal denken, da denken die an, leider gibt es das nicht mehr unter Windows 11,
da denken die an den alten Terminal-Prompt.
Und das alte Terminal-Programm, also quasi so die Standard-Batch-Windows-Shell, wie heißt die eigentlich überhaupt? Command-Terminal oder so.
Wenn man nur das hier kennt, dann will man kein Terminal und dann will man auch kein CLI benutzen, weil es einfach nur abgrundtief bodenlos schlecht ist.
Und das kann ich den Leuten unter Windows noch nicht mal übel nehmen, weil da ist es einfach scheiße.
Und die denken halt, dass es unter Linux auch so scheiße ist. Es ist es aber nicht.
Unter Linux ist es das Beste, was es gibt.
Ja, von CMD.
Kommt aus.
Ja, aber trotzdem, früher oder später ein bisschen Command-Line unter Linux ist nicht verkehrt und ich behaupte sogar mal, früher oder später kommt niemand dran vorbei.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm. Ich finde auch blöd, dass das immer so als Negativpunkt geht.
Geframed wird von Linux. Du musst manchmal wieder Command-Line. Das ist nicht. Das ist eines der größten Vorteile, die du unter Linux hast.
Umso mehr du dich da mal ein bisschen damit auseinandersetzt, umso früher, umso besser, weil es einfach nicht zu vergleichen ist mit dem Shit unter Windows.
Und install it in seconds. How is it worse than opening up a web browser, searching for an application, don't click on a malicious link that might be advertised, download the .e.
Na gut, unter Linux machst du n.
p.m. Update und hast auch irgendeinen Shit auf der Kiste.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz so schlimm wie früher.
Ja, nur dass der Windows Store halt suckt.
Aber immerhin, wir haben jetzt ja WinGet.
Was eigentlich auch nur eine komplette Krücke ist, versus ein Paketmanager unter Linux.
Immerhin.
Ach ja, und falls jetzt jemand fragt, warum WinGet nur eine Krücke ist, das liegt nicht so sehr an WinGet selbst, sondern an dem Wildwuchs, wie Windows Software über die Jahre installiert werden kann.
Du hast mindestens fünf verschiedene Installer, mindestens, mindestens, wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel mehr, mindestens fünf verschiedene Installer Möglichkeiten, die es unter Windows gibt.
Das seht ihr allein schon daran, dass es noch, dass es Software gibt, die nur hier auftaucht.
Das seht ihr allein schon daran, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass es noch, dass
dafür geeignet ist, ausgeführt zu werden, ohne dass man was klicken muss, dann kann auch Vingate es nicht einfach installieren und deinstallieren.
Und man sieht bei Vingate oft genug noch irgendwelche komischen Installer aufploppen und sonst was und Sachen, die nicht richtig aninstalliert werden.
Das liegt nicht an Vingate, das liegt an dem Wildwuchs der Installer von Windows und da kann Vingate eigentlich nichts für,
Aber trotzdem ist es halt im Vergleich zu dem, wie das unter Linux läuft, immer noch komplette Krücke.
Nix F.
Es geht immer noch.
Alles gut.
Ist nix.
Hier ist nix F.
Keine Framedrops.
Scoop macht das.
Ja, das machen alle Sachen unter Windows so.
Weil es so einen Installer-Wildwuchs gibt.
Das hast du halt unter Linux nicht.
Unter Linux hat halt jede Distribution ihr eigenes Package-Format.
Da ist ganz klar geregelt, wo kommen die Binaries hin, wo kommen Pre-Install, wo kommen Post-Install-Skripts hin.
Deswegen funktioniert das auch so gut.
Und ein riesen Vorteil, den du zumindest mit den offiziellen Packages unter Linux-Distributionen hast,
die sind auch getestet.
Die kommen quasi von, guckt euch Debian an.
Debian hat jedes Package-Maintainer, der sich darum kümmert, dass das ordentlich funktioniert auf der aktuellen Distribution.
Dass es jetzt ordentlich installiert ist, dass die Default-Settings gescheit sind.
Das hast du unter Windows nicht.
WinJet führt halt nur die normalen Default-Installer aus.
Und wie gut und schlecht die sind, ja, ist einmal dahingestellt.
Also WinJet ist immer noch eine ziemliche Krücke unter Windows, aber besser als nix.
...learn some of its useful features.
For example, one thing that annoyed me about the desktop environment Gnome was,
that you couldn't create files or links with a right-click.
But little did I know, that all I had to do was,
to drop a template file into the templates directory, and now it works.
The awesome thing about this way of doing it is,
that if you often need to create new files that have a similar layout,
you save the file once in here and can automatically generate a copy of it.
Customization in general is a huge plus point for Linux,
because many desktop environments allow you to create your own personalized workflow.
And for those who don't really care about that and just want to...
Wer Options haben will, muss eh KDE verwenden.
Und wer von Optionen erschlagen werden will, so sagen wir es mal.
Wer von Optionen erschlagen werden will, der muss KDE verwenden.
...system that just...
Und wer einfach nur was haben will, was nicht in den Weg kommt, der benutzt i3.
Und ist alle Probleme los. Easy.
Guck mal, i3 kann sogar Fenster, wenn man will. Guck hier.
Man will zwar meistens keine Fenster in i3, aber i3 kann sogar Fenster, wenn es sein muss.
...works, then Linux also offers something for them.
The GNOME Desktop Environment is my personal recommendation for most.
Ich mag GNOME nicht.
It feels different from Windows, which makes it a unique and fun experience.
If you want something more customizable or more bleeding edge, then you can go for KDE Plasma.
Which supports FreeSync and better scaling.
Ich mag KDE auch nicht.
And of course, tons and tons of more desktop environments out there.
But what you go for is...
Ich mag eigentlich gar kein Linux Desktop.
...entirely your choice.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, wenn ich eins verwenden müsste, dann wahrscheinlich Mint mit Cinnamon oder sowas.
Aber zum Glück geht i3 wunderbar.
I for once can say that I really don't enjoy using Windows anymore.
Mainly, because I've grown accustomed to a new workflow that just suits me so much better.
And if I find something...
Ja.
...that I...
Pass auf, jetzt kommt das neue Destiny Addon raus oder jetzt lädt wieder Windows.
...like, I simply change it.
This is much harder to do in Windows and I'm done with it.
Das stimmt.
If you've liked this video, then please make sure to show it with a like and why don't you also...
Naja, war jetzt nicht wirklich was Neues.
Und die Probleme, die ich in meinem Video da angesprochen habe, so finde ich, die stehen auch immer noch.
Neuer PC, das müsst ihr wissen.
Ja.
Dass es viel Geld kostet.
Müssten wir wissen.
Die Anzeige ist verkehrt.
Die Anzeige, die Anzeige ist verkehrt.
Manchmal, das liegt, das liegt an dem...
Das liegt an dem Addon.
Manchmal, manchmal backt das rum mit dem Abfragen der Likes und Dislikes.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Neuer PC, das müsst ihr wissen.
Ja, dass er teuer ist, müssen wir wissen.
NordVPN, müssen wir wissen.
Grafikkarte, Prozessor.
Okay, let's go.
16 Minuten...
Oh, nee, ich glaube, das ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Im Prinzip, das Einzige, was man wissen muss, ist, dass die meisten Fertig-PCs sacken.
Weil ich allerdings sagen muss, ich habe in letzter Zeit öfters mal...
Also, ich habe selbst schon Jahrzehnte keinen Fertig-PC mehr gekauft.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit öfters mal Reddit-Posts gesehen, dass es doch die ein oder anderen halbwegs brauchbaren Fertig-PCs gibt.
Also, ich rede jetzt so...
Also, ich rede jetzt so hier...
Aldi und so.
Was man sich natürlich kaufen kann, ist Hardware-Rat oder sowas in der Richtung.
Lange nichts mehr davon gehört, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, die gibt es immer noch.
Ja.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Haben sie nicht.
Mit den Dislikes funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Also, ganz am Anfang war das so.
Die Dislikes waren noch über die YouTube-AP abfragbar und wurden einfach nur versteckt.
Das ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so.
Jetzt wird das quasi hochgerechnet aus den Dislikes der Leute, die das Addon verwenden.
Du sharest quasi deine Dislikes über das Addon.
Und dann wird das irgendwie hochgerechnet anhand der Views und der Likes und so.
Das ist, glaube ich, relativ genau.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Ab jetzt Zahlen für Windows 10.
Oh nee, nicht nochmal Windows.
Das perfekte Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Da...
Ey, Dungeon Keeper, Leute, ohne Mist.
Eines der besten Games überhaupt, die je gemacht wurden.
Das erste Dungeon Keeper.
Keeper FX.
Das gibt's doch schon ewig.
Das habe ich euch sogar mal kurz im Stream gezeigt.
Das ist vor Jahren schon, Keeper FX.
Keeper FX ist quasi Dungeon Keeper Reimplementierung für moderne PCs.
Du brauchst aber immer noch das Original.
Zumindest war das damals so.
Du brauchst jetzt noch das Original.
Du musst da drin ein paar Dateien überschreiben.
Das ist...
Also, Dungeon Keeper ist immer noch ein mega-nices Game.
Ja.
Und gerade, wenn man das spielen kann in höherer Auflösung.
Und...
Mit ein bisschen höher aufgelöstem UI und besserem UI und vielleicht ein paar...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was es sonst noch so gab in Keeper FX.
Das Spiel ist mega-nice.
Also, ohne Scheiß, für mich ist Dungeon Keeper immer noch eines der besten Games, die je gemacht wurden.
Müssen Sie sich das Video angucken, aber...
Wer Dungeon Keeper nicht gespielt hat, kann man sich bei GOG kaufen für ein Appel und ein Ei.
Und mit Keeper FX läuft es in hoher Auflösung auf modernen PCs und sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Was daran liegt, dass man halt Pixel-Grafik hat.
Und Pixel-Grafik halt...
Und Pixel-Grafik halt prinzipiell relativ gut gealtert ist.
Damit das böse Getriebe reibungslos...
Ja.
Also, für ein Spiel von 1900...
1995 oder so...
Finde ich, geht das...
Ich meine, das Original hatte halt, glaube ich, 600...
640x480 Auflösung.
Oder unter DOS 320x240 oder sowas.
Konnte komplett knicken.
Aber das war halt schon nice.
Das war richtig...
War ein richtig gutes Game.
Und ich finde den ersten Teil auch besser als den zweiten Teil.
Und bei GOG...
Kostet das auch so gut wie nix.
1...
1,39€, Leute!
1,39€.
Kann man schon machen.
Ja.
Das Ding ist halt, dass es damals halt super pixelig war.
Guck.
Das war die...
By the way.
Das hier ist die Original-Auflösung.
Ihr habt die Auflösung versus das andere gesehen.
Ja.
Gut.
Ich meine, die Ego-Perspektive der Kreaturen ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so gut gealtert.
Das hier ist auf jeden Fall schon mit KeeperFX.
Das ist viel zu hoch auflösend.
Hier neben.
Haben die KeeperFX schon integriert hier?
Weil die Screenshots sind...
Die Screenshots...
Wobei doch, die könnten tatsächlich original sein.
Aber das hier ist glaube ich viel zu hoch auflösen.
Ja.
Zumindest Dungeon Keeper, wer es nicht gespielt hat, mega nice Game.
Der erste Teil.
Der zweite ist auch nicht schlecht, aber ich mag den ersten Teil mehr.
Und gerade mit KeeperFX, finde ich, ist der superior gegen den zweiten.
Was ist das?
Jeder...
Jeden Tag League of Legends.
Geld verdienen mit eSport.
In guten Sachen.
Der Fight war...
Ein LOL-Coach.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Da kann man bestimmt viel Kohle mitmachen, aber die meisten machen damit wahrscheinlich nicht viel Kohle.
Klar kann man damit Geld machen.
Es gibt sogar Leute, die machen das beruflich.
Da gibt es natürlich nur eine Handvoll Leute.
Naja, es gibt schon mehrere Teams.
Ein paar Leute im Vergleich zu der Spielermasse.
Gehen, klar.
Ich würde sagen, das geht in der heutigen Zeit so gut wie noch nie zuvor.
Okay.
Ich lasse mich jetzt Cheebaiten von diesem GameStar-Video.
Ich wette mit euch, dass es null mit Half-Life 3 zu tun hat, dass da irgendwas im Busch ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es einfach nur krasser Cheebait.
Half-Life 3.
Ein Name, der einst eine große Hoffnung trug, doch über die Jahre immer mehr zum Running-Gag verkommen ist.
Seit über 15 Jahren warten wir schon auf die Fortsetzung zu einer der besten Shooter-Serien aller Zeiten.
Aber warum dauert das eigentlich so lange?
Ich meine, es gab noch kein schlechtes Half-Life-Game.
Es gab halt auch nicht viele Half-Life-Games.
Denn das Gute ist, Valve muss es ja auch nicht übers Knie brechen.
Die haben mit Steam unendliche Gelddruckmaschine am Start.
Chef Gabe Newell vor ein paar Tagen zum 25-jährigen Jubiläum des ersten Half-Life-Spiels.
Und dieses Motto beherzigte der Entwickler schon Ende der 90er Jahre.
Es gibt ja auch kein Left 4 Dead 3.
... von Half-Life 1, weil die Machern fertiges, ausgereiftes Spiel...
Oder auch kein Portal 3.
... ob es aktuell nun aber überhaupt den Ansatz...
Alter, was ist mit dem Aim der Spieleredakteure immer los?
Er muss es ja nicht. Er muss es ja nicht.
Der muss es nicht. Und ich hab auch nicht das krasseste Aim aller Zeiten.
... der 90er Jahre. Valve versch...
Aber what the fuck?
... damals den Release von Half-Life 1, weil die Machern fertiges, ausgereiftes Spiel abliefern wollten.
Ob es aktuell nun aber überhaupt den Ansatz eines neuen Spiels gibt...
What the fuck?
... ob Half-Life 3 also in der aktiven Entwicklung ist...
War das Controller Aim? Das sah nach Controller Aim aus.
... das verrät Gabe Newell nicht.
Wir wissen aber, dass der Ego-Shooter immer mal wieder in Entwicklung war.
Verschiedene Konzeptphasen...
Jetzt ohne... Ich will ihn nicht schlecht machen.
Ich mein, als Spieleredakteur brauchst du sicherlich noch weit andere Qualitäten als unbedingt Aim in Ego-Shooter.
Aber das ist teilweise echt immer so, Painstamps sich anzugucken.
... und letztlich wohl immer wieder abgebrochen wurde.
Immerhin gab's dann aber 2020 mit Half- Alyx einen neuen, wirklich...
Wozu sie ja gesagt haben, es war ursprünglich mal Stand im Raum, es Half-Life 3 zu nennen.
Aber sie haben es absichtlich nicht Half-Life 3 genannt.
Auch um den Druck von den Leuten ein bisschen runterzunehmen, die das Spiel entwickeln.
Und ja, weil es wohl...
Nach all den Jahren jetzt ein VR-Titel Half-Life 3...
Also ich finde, es war die richtige Entscheidung, es nicht Half-Life 3 zu nennen.
... sehr guten Ableger der Reihe.
Das VR-Spiel ist sogar für die Geschichte der Hauptserie richtig wichtig, aber da wollen wir hier nicht zu viel verraten.
Don't worry, it's unloaded.
Doch wenn es nun schon ein Half- Alyx gibt...
Was ist denn dann bei Half-Life 3 schiefgelaufen?
Beziehungsweise bei der dritten Episode von Half-Life 2?
Schließlich dachten wir 2007, also nach dem Release von Half-Life 2 Episode 2 noch...
Ja, dachten wir.
... dass das etwa der nächste Schritt für Half-Life werden würde.
Von einem Half-Life 3 war damals noch gar keine Rede.
Doch der dritte bezahlte...
Ja, Valve hatte damals gesagt, sie wollen jetzt eher zu so episodic Content übergehen.
Das hat halt genau für zwei Episoden gehalten.
Sie für Half-Life 2 kam nie.
Die Story endete für lange Zeit mit einem schrecklichen Cliffhanger.
Ja.
Ich bin jetzt mal auf Spurensuche gegangen und zeichne in diesem Video die unvollendete Entstehungsgeschichte von Half-Life 3 nach.
Oder besser gesagt die Nicht-Entstehungsgeschichte.
Aha! Von wegen! Valve ist endlich bereit für Half-Life 3! Von wegen! Ich wusste, dass es ein Cheap-Bait-Video ist, Alter!
Also eine Reise zu vielen verlorenen Visionen, in einige Sackgassen und am Ende gibt es sogar einen kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer.
Aber jetzt gehen wir erstmal zurück zum Anfang.
Das war so klar!
Weil ich hätte das 100 pro mitbekommen, wäre wirklich... würde wirklich Half-Life 3 irgendwie anstehen, ey.
Für alle Anime- und Gaming-Fans haben wir zusammen mit Boostbox und Asus ein absolutes Schmuckstück für euch.
Ah, Anime-Fans, weil... ah ja, verstehe.
Die... das...
Wir präsentieren euch Deutschland exklusiv die Gamestar-PC Evangelion 02 Edition.
Highlights wie die Asus ROG Strix, GeForce RX...
Highlights wie die Asus ROG Strix, GeForce RTX 4090 und das Asus ROG...
Moment! Sehe ich das richtig?
Das Netzteil hat nen LCD? Hat nen Display?
Da... okay.
Da musst du aber schon Hardcare... Hardcore-Mäßig drauf sein, dass du das...
...dass du das enjoyst, ey.
...90 Hero im Evangelion 02 Look garantieren euch flüssiges und ultrascharfes Gameplay, auch bei 4K-Auflösung.
Schnell sein lohnt sich. Der Gamestar-PC...
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie meine Wasserkühlung, oder?
...durch bei 4K-Auflösung. Schnell sein...
Sieht ein bisschen... sieht ein bisschen aus... sieht ein bisschen aus wie... wie... wie meine Wasserkühlung, oder?
Wobei die Dinger sehen halt alle so aus.
...durch bei 4K-Auflösung. Schnell sein lohnt sich. Der Gamestar-PC Evangelion 02 Edition...
Ach, das ist der CPU-Kühler, das ist nicht das Netzteil. Sorry, ich hab mich verguckt.
Das ist der... der Kühlblock für die... für die Wasserkühlung. Mit nem...
Okay, der hat... der... mach... okay, Leute. Macht's noch wirrer, dass das Ding ein LCD-Display drauf hat.
...ist auf 52 Stück limitiert. Alle Infos unter gamestar.de slash eva2.
Ja, Beste.
Half-Life 1 schlägt 1998...
Ihhh! Ihhh!
Der spielt mit dem Blue-Shift-Mod... ähm, Texture... nicht Texture... ähm, Models-Pack.
Das ist ja... das ist sehr unbeliebt in der Half-Life-Community, das Blue-Shift-Model-Pack.
...90 hohe Welten.
Es legt einen starken Fokus auf seine Story und Begeisterung.
Und es leistet insbesondere durch die immersive Erzählweise.
Als Physiker Gordon Freeman erleben wir, wie ein Experiment schiefgeht und Aliens auf die Erde stürmen.
Das Besondere daran, es gibt keine Zwischensequenzen oder Texttafeln zwischen den Levels.
Stattdessen erleben wir die ganze Geschichte direkt aus der Ego-Ansicht, also durch Gordons Augen.
Das ist 1998 durchaus außergewöhnlich, denn damals trennen viele Spiele Erzählung und Gameplay noch vergleichsweise streng.
Nach einer erfüllten Mission in Command & Conquer gibt es beispielsweise einen kleinen Renderfilm
oder eine Live-Action.
Sogar in Quake 2 hattest du dieses Intro, wo sie abgestürzt sind und immer diesen Ladebildschirm zwischendurch.
Das hat Half-Life schon echt gut gemacht.
Zumal man auch sagen muss, Half-Life war, also würde ich sagen, eines der ersten Ego-Shooter,
die ansatzweise sowas wie eine Story hatten.
Es ist jetzt nicht wirklich so, als hätte Half-Life...
Ich finde, ganz ehrlich, ihr wisst, ich bin ein riesen Half-Life-Fan.
Und für mich ist es eines der besten Games, die es gibt.
Aber man soll jetzt mal nicht so tun, als hätte Half-Life so die super krass...
...diepe Story gehabt.
Und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass selbst Valve viele Sachen nicht wusste, was sie eigentlich bedeuten sollen.
Die einfach nur eingebaut wurden, dass es cool ist.
Ich meine, da sieht man...
Guckt euch den G-Man an.
G-Man ist in Half-Life 1 so ein random Regierungsdude.
Vermutlich.
Man weiß es nicht genau.
Es ist absichtlich ein bisschen offengelassen.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat sich garantiert bei Valve niemand was dabei gedacht, was da wirklich dahinter stecken könnte.
Das siehst du allein schon daran, dass Half-Life 1 mit Half-Life 2 ja eigentlich außer Gordon Freeman nichts wirklich zu tun hat.
Okay, es kommt ein Charakter wieder vor.
Ja, es wird Bezug genommen zu Black Mesa.
Aber das ganze Setting ist einfach komplett anders.
Ja.
Und das war denen nicht klar.
Es ist nicht so, als hätten...
Und das war denen während der Half-Life 2 Entwicklung sicherlich auch nicht klar.
Ja.
Und vieles, vieles in Half-Life ist super vage.
Also es ist nicht, als hätte Half-Life eine krass diepe Story.
Aber die haben Story genug, dass es es interessant gemacht hat.
Und das war das erste Game, was das versucht hat.
Zumindest was mir so, was mir so einfällt.
In der Richtung.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, Half-Life, wir haben es letztens erst wieder mit einem Mod durchgespielt.
Beste Szene.
Counter-Strike hätte es in der Form sicherlich nicht gegeben ohne Half-Life.
Sowas ähnliches.
Vielleicht.
Es gab ja damals, vielleicht kann sich noch einer daran erinnern.
Es gab ja quasi so eine Art Counter-Strike für...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es ein Unreal oder ein Unreal Tournament Mod gewesen ist.
Und ich habe auch vergessen, wie es hieß.
Das war mehr oder weniger Counter-Strike für Unreal Tournament.
Und...
Oder für Unreal?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, wie das hieß.
Kennt das noch irgendjemand?
Was ist das denn?
Das hieß nicht Counter...
Das hieß...
Strike Force?
Nee.
Oder?
Tactical Ops.
Das ist es, glaube ich.
Oder?
Es entstand aus einer Modifikation des Spiels Unreal.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Genau.
Ich glaube, das meine ich.
Ja.
Also, Ideen gab es da drum herum ja auch schon.
Ist Story Pause.
Doom, Quake und Co. bieten ohnehin fast gar keine Geschichte.
Und aufwendige Skriptsequenzen wie in Call of Duty sind noch Jahre weit weg.
Doch Half-Life macht den Anfang.
Ja.
Und es gibt schon drin in einem Modus...
Ah, dieses...
Ich mag das Texture Pack nicht.
Das ist das BlueShift, äh, nicht Texture, das BlueShift Models Pack.
Da haben die versucht, die Waffenmodels und die NPC Models ein bisschen zu modernisieren.
Ich finde, die haben nichts mehr mit den originalen Models zu tun.
Die choreografierten Abenteuer.
Das geht schon mit der legendären Fahrt in den Forschungskomplex Black Mesa.
Ja.
Beste, beste, beste.
Wo wir viele Ereignisse um uns herum frei beobachten können und teils sogar müssen.
This Train is Inbound vom Level 3.
Unser Blick ist frei.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
From Level 3, ich kann es nicht mehr weiter.
Also, es ist so schlimm bei mir.
Ich kann, wenn wir es hören,
kann ich das mitsprechen.
Also, ich kann das Intro mehr oder weniger mitreden noch.
The Strain is inborn from Level 3.
Auswendig kann ich es nicht, aber ich kann es mitsprechen.
So oft habe ich das Intro durchgespielt.
Matrix.at, danke schön für den Sub.
Wir müssen aber auch aufpassen, dass wir alle Details mitbekommen.
1998 ist das neu und revolutionär.
Das Half-Life-Intro schreibt damit Spielegeschichte.
Finde ich heute auch noch.
Klar, du hast heute Spiele, die machen erst mal ein bisschen Intro.
Aber so diese Ingame...
Ich finde dich immer noch einzigartig an Half-Life.
Später im Spiel folgen dann jede Menge weitere Skriptsequenzen.
Mal klein wie hier, mal groß wie hier.
Das Geschrei der Scientists.
Es gibt herausfordernde Gefechte gegen clevere Gegner
und ein Mix aus Geschicklichkeits- und Rätselpassagen.
Alles in allem ein genialer Cocktail.
Ja.
Beste.
Half-Life 2.
Half-Life 2 setzt 2004 auf Innovationen und glänzt dieses Mal vor allem mit einem markanten...
Physics Engine war so das Ding schlechthin von...
Man, erinnert sich noch einer, wahrscheinlich nicht, das ist zu lang her,
dass die auch ganz schön geschwindelt haben so bei Half-Life 2.
Erinnert sich noch einer an den Half-Life 2 Source-Code-Leak?
War das nicht sogar irgendein deutscher Hacker?
Irgendein 16-jähriger Deutscher, der den Half-Life-Source-Code geleakt hat damals?
Ja.
Und dann zumindest rausgekommen ist, dass sie ziemlich, ziemlich Mist erzählt haben in ihrer Präsentation.
In der ersten Half-Life-2-Präsentation gab es so eine Szene,
da war Gordon in einem Haus drin und die NPC-Gegner haben versucht, in dieses Haus einzudringen
und haben dann halt ganz viele super intelligente Sachen gemacht.
Und Half-Life und Valve hat halt gesagt, ey, unsere Advanced-AI macht das von sich aus
und durch den Source-Code-Leak ist halt rausgekommen,
das war halt alles gescriptet für die Demo.
Also es wurde damals schon viel Mist erzählt.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass das Game was rausgekommen ist, gut war.
...Kanten-Art-Design, tollen Gesichtsanimationen und natürlichen Texten.
Ja, also das muss man echt sagen, die Gesichtsanimationen und generell die Gesichter der Source-Engine,
die waren jahrelang wirklich Maßstab.
...Physikberechnung. Wir stapeln Steine, bauen Brücken und ballern später vor allem mit der Gravity-Gun alles um.
...Physik-Engine.
Die kreative Waffe zieht nahezu jeden Gegenstand an und schießt ihn dann auch wieder zurück.
Und selbstverständlich bleibt die Story-Stärke des ersten Teils bestehen
und setzt mit schickeren Modellen und natürlichen Bewegungen, Motion-Capture sei Dank, noch einen drauf.
Eine so echt wirkende Begleiterin wie Alyx gibt es bis zu diesem Abenteuer nicht.
Hier.
Das hat auch sehr viele Modder inspiriert.
Lass mich dir einen Trink kaufen.
Oh, und übrigens, schön, dass ich dich endlich treffen konnte.
Danke.
Selbst neben dem eigentlichen Spiel schreibt Entwickler Valve Innovationen groß.
Half-Life 2 setzt zum Start den damals noch sehr umstrittenen Download-Klären Steam voraus und setzt das Haupt...
Es ist auch witzig, ne?
Damals die ganze Welt rumgeschrien, so nach dem Motto, oh, scheiße, Online-Steam und was ist das für ein Kack.
Und jetzt ist es umgedreht.
Wenn jetzt ein Game nicht mehr auf Steam rauskommt, sagen die Leute, not on Steam, not buy, so nach dem Motto.
Also, da seht ihr mal, was da 20 Jahre ausmachen.
Ja, also.
Also, 2000, 2004 quasi, 2003, 2004, oh, scheiße, Steam, geh weg, gib mir CD.
Und 2023, 2024, wie, Game kommt nicht auf Steam, dann kauf ich's nicht.
Ne, damals hatte noch nicht jeder ein schnelles Internet.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, die Spiele waren im Vergleich zu heute auch nicht so groß.
Ich mein, wie groß war Half-Life 2? 3 Gigabyte oder so?
Jetzt hat es trotzdem lange gedauert.
Aber man konnte ja, wohlgemerkt, man musste die Sachen...
Man konnte die Sachen ja nicht runterladen, zwangsläufig, von Steam.
War es nicht so, dass man Half-Life 2 einfach nur Steam gebraucht hat, um es spielen zu können?
Also, ich glaube, man konnte Half-Life 2 ganz normal noch kaufen.
Aber man musste halt Steam haben, um es zu spielen.
GOG kann gar nicht besser, kann überhaupt nicht besser sein als Steam.
GOG ist was anderes.
Versucht mal beispielsweise die neuesten Games, wenn es nicht gerade Ausnahmespiele sind, die damit fein sind.
So, ich glaube, Witcher 3 gab es auch als GOG.
Release und sowas, wirst du die auf GOG gar nicht finden.
Also, das ist ein 20 Jahre Unterschied von, oh, fuck Steam zu, ohne Steam kauf ich's nicht.
Spiel mit DLC-Erweiterung in Episodenform fort.
Über beide Neuerungen kann man streiten, aber es zeigt, Valve ist vorne dabei, wenn es um neue Ideen geht.
Die Episoden sollen beispielsweise verhindern, dass wir wieder etliche Jahre auf eine Fortsetzung der Half-Life-Serie warten müssen.
Ja, habt ihr so gedacht.
6 bis 12 Monate soll die Entwicklung einer Episode dauern.
Aber das mit dem Episoden-Content war natürlich clever auch.
Für Downloads über Steam und alles.
Die machen das ja nicht alles aus reiner Nächstenliebe.
Und Half-Life 2 Episode 1 erscheint 2006, fast zwei Jahre nach dem Hauptspiel.
Episode 2 braucht noch einmal knapp 17 Monate und kommt 2007 auf den Markt.
Um die bereits angekündigte finale Episode 3 wird es danach still.
Bis 2008 weicht Valve der Frage nach einem Release aus und veröffentlicht lediglich kleine Info- und Artwork-Happen.
Das Spiel soll kommen, man brauche aber etwas mehr Zeit.
Parallel werkelt das Entwicklerteam von Dungeon Point Studios an einem Spiel rund um die Stadt Ravenholm.
Das Projekt erblickt allerdings nie das Licht der Welt und landet sogar kurz bei Arkane, den Machern der Dishonored-Reihe.
Mehr Details über dieses eingestellte Half-Life-Abenteuer findet ihr in einem ausführlichen Video auf unserem Kanal.
Den Link gibt's in der Videobeschreibung.
Von Ravenholm weist die Öffentlichkeit allerdings lange Zeit erstmal gar nichts und auch um Half-Life 2 Episode 3 bleibt es weiterhin still.
Erst 2011 veröffentlicht Valve endlich Neuigkeiten.
Die sind aber wenig erfreulich.
Valve trennt sich vom Episoden-Format.
Die Pläne für Episode 3 seien zu ambitioniert gewesen und würden den Rahmen des Formats sprengen.
Die haben ja auch schon viel, wie soll ich sagen, sich Sachen aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt so über die Jahre hinweg.
Aber gut, ich meine, was sollen sie auch auf die permanente Nachfrage sagen?
Auf der anderen Seite, was sollen die Fans machen außer nachfragen?
Ich verstehe aber beides.
War Dota 2 nicht das erste Game, was Source 2 verwendet hat?
Also nicht zu Release, nicht zu Release, quasi als Patch, als Patch.
War nicht Dota 2 das erste Game, was Source Engine 2 bekommen hat als Grundlage?
... das Half-Life-Spiel auch vernünftig umsetzen zu können.
Dieses Detail wird übrigens später nochmal sehr, sehr wichtig.
Das Ende von Episode 3 bedeutet 2011 aber zunächst mal, dass wir ab dann ein waschechtes Half-Life 3 erwarten.
Valve selbst kommentiert das damals übrigens nicht.
2012 gibt es dafür erstmals inoffizielle Erklärungen, warum der Shooter so lange auf sich warten lässt.
Mehrere Webseiten berichten, dass Valve bereits verschiedene Prototypen ausprobiert hat
und deswegen die Gesamtentwicklung mehrmals neu starten musste.
Da ist unter anderem von einem Open-World-Shooter samt Rollenspielanleihen die Rede.
Bestätigt oder kommentiert hat Valve das ab?
Ich traue Valve durchaus zu, dass sie das gut hinbekommen würden im Half-Life-Universum.
Ich glaube, dass sie das gut hinbekommen würden im Half-Life-Universum.
Ich finde einfach, Half-Life ist kein Open-World-Game.
Vielleicht bin ich dazu oldschool, aber ich finde, Half-Life profitiert einfach unglaublich durch den roten Faden, den es gibt.
Und das als Open-World, ich kann es mir schwer vorstellen.
Aber nie. 2013 gibt es den ersten richtigen Dämpfer.
Synchronsprecher John Patrick Lowry behauptet, dass aktuell niemand mehr an Half-Life 3 arbeitet.
Beziehungsweise er mutmaßt es.
Denn er weiß nicht, was bei Valve hinter den Kulissen passiert.
Diese Art von Gerüchten und Meldungen nimmt in den nächsten Jahren immer mehr zu.
Hier mal ein vermeintliches T-Shirt zu Teil 3, dort ein Release-Datum.
Aber nichts davon erweist sich als wahr und Valve schweigt munter weiter.
Was sollen sie auch machen?
2015 verlässt Art-Designer Ted Backman dann das Entwicklerstudio.
Backman war unter anderem für die Designs von Headcrabs und Combine maßgeblich verantwortlich.
Der Weggang bringt also natürlich sofort wieder die Gerüchteküche zum Brot.
Hat Valve Half-Life 3 vielleicht sogar schon eingestellt?
Oder verschiebt der Entwickler das Spiel aus Angst vor anderen großen Titeln?
Die Gerüchte kochen so hoch, dass Valve sich tatsächlich macht.
Also das ist glaube ich das einzige, wenn du Valve bist und Half-Life 3 nicht Angst haben musst.
Dass es untergeht versus irgendwelche anderen Games.
Sollte Half-Life 3 kommen, die Leute flippen aus.
Es muss aber auch was taugen.
Weil es dauert jahrelang.
Dann sich sowas aufzubauen im Endeffekt.
Also den Ruf, den die Half-Life-Reihe genießt.
Es braucht aber nur einen scheiß Teil, um das zu vernichten.
Gerade nach so langer Zeit.
Das Spiel ist immer noch...
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich bezweifle auch, dass wir hier Half-Life 3 bekommen.
Damals, dass das Studio niemals aus Angst vor anderen Titeln ein Spiel verschieben würde.
Ja, würden sie auch nicht.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Was bei Half-Life 3 ist, das verrät Laidlaw nicht.
Im selben Jahr geht Valve aber eine Partnerschaft mit VR-Hersteller HTC ein.
Wird Half-Life 3 dadurch ein reines VR-Abenteuer?
Nein.
Story-Autor Chad Falicek schiebt dieser Idee auf der EGX 2015 sehr bestimmt einen Regel vor.
Und er sagt die Wahrheit.
Valve will die Community mit so einem Schritt nicht verprellen.
VR bleibt aber...
Wisst ihr, deswegen, das ist auch eines der Gründe, was ich vorhin angesprochen habe,
dass man es nicht Half-Life 3 genannt hat.
Was auch wirklich die sinnvollere Entscheidung war.
Bann für das Studio.
Hinter den Kulissen weckelt man bereits...
...an einigen VR-Prototypen.
Einen davon kündigt der Entwickler vier Jahre später als der Spin-Off Half-Life Alyx an.
2015 ist Half-Life VR aber noch fern...
Ich würde das ja sehr gerne spielen.
Problem ist, ich will mir nicht nur für ein Game eine VR-Headset kaufen.
...die Gerüchte zu Teil 3 reißen hingegen weiterhin nicht ab.
Ich weiß, man kann das Spiel mit Mod ohne VR-Brille, aber das ist es dann auch nicht, oder?
...in einem Dota 2-Update soll auf den Shooter-Nachfolger hinweisen
und auch eine Steam-Release-Liste macht Fans Hoffnungen.
Allerdings kommt auch hier am Ende nichts bei rum.
Die Liste stammt nicht einmal von Valve selbst.
Wie Gabe Newell später zugibt, erlauben sich seine Kollegen gerne mal Scherze über Half-Life 3.
Auch die bereits angesprochenen T-Shirts, das waren alles nur Spiele von Valve-Mitarbeitern.
Würde mich auch nicht wundern.
Anfang 2016 müssen Fans von Half-Life erneut ganz stark sein.
Mark Laidlaw verlässt nach 19 Jahren seinen Arbeitgeber.
Laidlaw war maßgeblich für die Story von Half-Life verantwortlich.
Doch er betont, dass er vor allem aus Altersgründen aus der Branche verschwindet.
Er würde gerne noch hin und wieder...
...als Freelancer für Valve arbeiten.
Die Hoffnungen auf eine Half-Life-3-Story mit seinem Mitwirken sind also nicht ganz zerschlagen.
Ah, der freie Mann.
Ich bin froh, dass ich gesehen habe, dass zumindest du unverletzt bist.
Aber die Alex-Fans...
...sie sind krank.
2017 ist Episode 2 dann 10 Jahre alt.
Was mit Half-Life 3 los ist, will Valve immer noch nicht kommentieren.
Wie Game Informer aus einer Internet-Twelle bei Valve erfahren haben will,
steckt die Entwicklung zu diesem Zeitpunkt jedoch in
einer Sackgasse.
Der Informant des Spielemagazins verrät, Valve habe zwar bislang wirklich an Half-Life 3
gearbeitet, aber das Team hätte kein überzeugendes Konzept gefunden.
Die Prototypen hätten wohl von Echtzeitstrategie bis Action-Adventure viele Genres abgedeckt.
Vielleicht wird Half-Life 3 also am Ende gar kein Ego-Shooter?
Oder es gibt irgendwann noch weitere Ableger, eine Art Half-Life Wars zum Beispiel, wie
bei Halo?
Das sind natürlich Spekulationen.
Wie so vieles, wenn es um Half-Life 3 geht.
Stand 2017 gibt es aber erstmal kein Spiel, an dem noch gearbeitet wird.
Durch die vielen Sackgassen scheint es so, dass das Projekt Stück für Stück stürmt.
Das Gute, das Gute, was also den riesen Vorteil, den Valve hat, die haben halt unendlich Geld
durch Steam.
Die können sich das leisten, einfach da dran zu, ich meine, es ist nicht billig, ja.
Die können sich das leisten, da kontinuierlich dran zu basteln, wenn es auch sicherlich kein
jetzt hauptsächliches Team, was mit ganz vielen Leuten nur das macht, geben wird.
Aber sie können sich das leisten.
2017 gibt es ausnahmsweise aber auch mal gute oder zumindest gute Spiele.
Ich meine, Steam ist halt Geld-Druck.
Es gibt auch ganz spannende Nachrichten.
Wir erfahren nämlich erstmals Story-Details zu dem, was Half-Life 3 irgendwann mal werden
sollte.
Mark Laidlaw veröffentlicht ein Jahr nach seinem Weckgang von Valve einen Brief mit
der Story für ein mögliches Spiele-Projekt.
Ein Spiel, das Valve laut Laidlaw vielleicht sogar noch eines Tages umsetzen wird.
Die Namen sind zwar etwas abgeändert, aber es ist sehr deutlich, um welches Franchise
es hier geht.
Ein gewisser Gertie Freeman sucht in der Antarktis ein Schiff namens Hyperborea und…
Ja, das gibt es ja auch vor einer Weile schon.
Diese Aliens, die Disparate heißen.
Klar, hier ist die Borealis gemeint, das Schiff, das in Episode 1 und 2 eine große Rolle spielt.
Der Entwurf spricht von Zeitreisen zum Sieben-Stunden-Krieg, der vor Half-Life 2 stattgefunden hat, außerdem
soll es ein letztes finales Aufbäumen gegen die feindlichen Besatzer geben, also gegen
die Combine.
Am Ende beendet Gordon Freeman, ich meine Gertie Freeman, das Spiel mit den geschriebenen
Erwartet keine Berichte mehr von mir.
Dies ist meine letzte Episode.
Ja.
Das macht klar, das hier kann doch nur die nie fertiggestellte Geschichte von Half-Life
2, Episode 3 oder von Half-Life 3 sein, oder?
Tja, ich glaube nicht, dass wir jemals erleben werden, dass es noch rauskommt.
Auch wenn ich super gehypt wäre, noch zu meinen Lebzeiten Half-Life 3 zu sehen.
Antworten auf diese Frage gibt es zunächst keine.
Valve bleibt weiter stumm.
2019 kommt dafür der YouTuber Tyler McVicker dem VR-Projekt durch einen Insider auf die
Schliche.
Details kann er aber keine nennen.
Nur, dass es sich um ein Half-Life-Spiel handeln soll.
Zusätzlich entdeckt er im Code von Dota 2 den Begriff Citadel.
Und McVicker behält Recht.
Nur wenige Monate später macht Valve Half-Life Alyx offiziell.
Der VR-Ableger kommt bereits im März 2020 raus, rund neun Monate nach der neuen VR-Brille
Valve Index.
Zum geheimnisvollen Projekt Citadel sagt Valve jedoch bis heute nichts.
In Half-Life Alyx schlüpfen wir in die Haut der bekannten und titelgebenden Begleiterin
von Gordon Freeman.
Allerdings spielt der Ableger zunächst vor den Ereignissen von Half-Life.
Und das ist nicht so einfach.
Trotzdem wird die Geschichte auch für ein mögliches Half-Life 3 sehr sehr wichtig.
Für alle, die VR vielleicht nicht vertragen, ist es deshalb gut, dass gerade an einer sehr
guten No-VR-Mod für Alyx gearbeitet wird.
So könnt ihr die Geschichte noch vor Half-Life 3 nachholen.
Und beeilen müsst ihr euch damit auch nicht, denn trotz des...
Ja, okay, wenn das taugt als No-VR-Mod, dann werde ich mir das auch mal zu Gemüte führen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich würde es am liebsten gerne so spielen, wie sich das Valve gedacht
hat.
Das Ding ist nur, ich will mir halt nicht für ein Game eine VR-Brille kaufen.
Folgendes von Half- Alyx fehlt vom nächsten Serienteil erneut jede Spur.
Immerhin bleibt Alyx der Half-Life-Tradition treu und liefert nicht nur hohe Qualität,
sondern auch Innovationen im VR-Gaming.
Der Ableger kann so sehr begeistern, dass zeitweise sogar die Valve-Index-Headsets ausverkauft
sind.
Die Presse feiert den Shooter als den System-Seller für VR-Brillen und tatsächlich ist das Spiel
bis heute der Maßstab aller VR-Shooter.
Und das soll erst der Anfang sein.
Sollte es nicht sein, dann ist es schon der Anfang.
David Spire als auch Game-Designer Robin Walker versichern, dass Alyx eine Rückkehr
zur Half-Life-Welt ist und nicht der Abschluss.
Walker verrät, dass viele Mitarbeiter von Valve für lange Zeit sehr eingeschüchtert
von der Idee waren, einen Half-Life 3 zu entwickeln.
Dank Half- Alyx haben die Entwickler nun neues Selbstbewusstsein gesammelt, auch weil
sie hier ganz unbeschwert ihre Ideen umsetzen konnten.
Ein Half-Life 3 will trotzdem noch niemand bei Valve bestätigen.
Aber zumindest gibt es seit Jahren endlich wieder eine realistische...
Ich glaube, bis da was bestätigt wird, da muss es schon so weit sein.
...dass es fast fertig ist, bevor die offiziell da irgendwas bestätigen in der Richtung.
...Chance für einen neuen Hauptteil der Serie.
Vielleicht hat Alyx den Knoten gelöst und auch ein bisschen die Angst vor den unglaublich
hohen Erwartungen gedämpft, die mit Half-Life 3 verbunden sind.
Half- Alyx hat aber auch gezeigt, dass Valve für seine Spiele immer eine zündende
und vor allem unverbrauchte Idee benötigt.
Half-Life hatte die besondere Art, eine Geschichte zu erzählen, Half-Life 2 entstand rund um
die Physik und die Gravity Gun, die Episoden probierten neues Format aus und Alyx perfektionierte
VR.
Fehlt Half-Life 3 also diese zündende Idee?
Geht es deshalb nicht weiter?
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Nein?
Okay.
Ich hätte gedacht, könnte gut sein, könnte gut sein.
2020 veröffentlicht Valve die Doku Half- Alyx – Final Hours und gibt darin auch endlich
eine Antwort auf die Frage, warum wurde Half-Life 3 bis heute nicht fertig?
Demnach war der Shooter 2013 und 2014 mit einer ganz konkreten Idee in Entwicklung.
Valve orientierte sich an einer hauseigenen Marke, nämlich an Left 4.
Dieses Half-Life 3 setzte auf prozedural generierte Level.
Gleichzeitig hätte es nach wie vor von Hand gebaute Elemente gegeben und klingt im Grunde
wie ein Left 4 Dead mit richtiger Story-Kampagne.
Jeder Durchgang wäre dadurch ein bisschen anders gewesen und das hätte genau wie im
Zombie-Shooter den Wiederspielwert in die Höhe getrieben.
Und warum wurde dieses Half-Life 3 nie fertig?
Vielleicht hat's nichts getaucht?
Der Grund ist sehr viel einfacher als gedacht, die Source-2-Engine ist schuld.
Wir erinnern uns nochmal ein paar Minuten zurück, Valve wollte die neue Engine bauen, nachdem
die Pläne für Episode 3 zu ambitioniert wurden.
Die Entwicklung der Engine brachte aber Probleme mit sich.
Schon bei Half-Life 2 hatte Valve große Schwierigkeiten, weil das Studio Source-Engine und Spiel parallel
baute.
Deswegen dauerte die Entwicklung der direkten Fortsetzung Ende der 90er, Anfang der 2000er
mit rund 6 Jahren auch recht lang, also zumindest für damalige Verhältnisse.
In genau die gleiche Falle tappte Valve mit Half-Life 3 und der Source-2-Engine erneut.
Das gesamte technische Gerüst für den Shooter war schlicht noch nicht vorhanden, also zog
man aus der Erfahrung von Teil 2 letztlich auf.
Es gab letztlich Konsequenzen und stellte Half-Life 3 und alle anderen Projekte der
Marke vorerst ein.
Bevor irgendein Spiel entsteht, sollte erst einmal die Engine in ihren Grundzügen fertig
sein.
Das war sie dann 2015 und ab da nahm erst einmal die VR-Projekte im Zuge der HTC-Kooperation
Fahrt auf, die 2020 dann in Half- Alyx gipfelten.
Übrigens, die Final Hours Doku verrät auch, dass Half-Life 3 nicht das einzige eingestellte
Projekt ist.
Gleich 5 Half-Life-Spiele waren zeitweise in Entwicklung, darunter das bereits angesprochene
Ravenholm.
Die beiden VR-Projekte Shooter und Borealis.
Borealis sollte etwa die Invasion der Combine und den Sieben-Stunden-Krieg zeigen.
Die Geschichte auf dem titelgebenden Schiff nach Episode 2 weitererzählen.
Irgendwo in der Antarktis.
Und wer jetzt ein kleines Déjà-vu hat.
Ja.
Das ist genau die Story, die Mark Laidlaw 2017 veröffentlicht hat.
Das war's für heute.
Es war also nie die von Half-Life 3.
Half-Life 3 ist immer noch in weiter Ferne.
Immerhin kennen wir jetzt einige Gründe für die lange Wartezeit und die sind tatsächlich
gut nachvollziehbar.
Von der Sorge der Valve-Mitarbeiter, den Erwartungen nicht gerecht werden zu können, bis zur langen
Entwicklung der Source-2-Engine.
Am Ende könnte es aber vor allem Half- Alyx sein, das den Stein erneut ins Rollen bringt.
Der Erfolg des Projekts hat sicherlich für viel Motivation gesorgt und die besondere
Projektstruktur beim Entwickler Valve könnte jetzt dafür sorgen, dass es tatsächlich mit
Half-Life 3 weitergeht.
Bei Valve wird nämlich selten von oben herab ein Spiel geplant und an die Mitarbeiter
in Auftrag gegeben.
Stattdessen finden sich die Entwickler zu tief zusammen und wenn es überzeugende Ideen
und Konzepte gibt.
Und jetzt haben sie mit der aktuellen Source-Engine ja auch wieder einen starken Technik-Motor.
Gabe Newell bekräftigte 2021 jedenfalls noch einmal, dass Valve in Zukunft noch mehr Projekte
ankündigen will.
Engine und Hardware für viele kreative Ideen stehen ja mit VR-Brillen und dem Steam Deck
bereit.
Vielleicht gehört ja auch Citadel dazu, das immer noch von Valve und Half-Life-Mitarbeiter
unkommentiert durchs Netz geistert.
Laut Insider-Infos soll es sich dabei um eine Mischung aus Shooter- und Echtzeit-Strategie
handeln.
Vielleicht wäre das ja ein guter Testcase für ein Half-Life für Steam Deck mit einem
Mix aus Gamepad und Touch-Kontrollen.
2023 gibt es zwar immer noch keine fest angekündigten neuen Half-Life-Projekte, aber die fertige
Source-2-Engine, der Cliffhanger von Alyx und der kommerzielle Erfolg des VR-Shooters,
das alles stellt die Weichen für Half-Life 3.
Die Chancen für die Fortsetzung standen jedenfalls noch nie so gut wie heute.
Nur wann und was es dann wird…
Dann ist der Titel ja streng genommen nicht falsch, aber mir war von Anfang an klar,
dass es hier nicht…
Das hätte ich auf jeden Fall mitbekommen.
… noch einfach etwas gedulden, nur bitte nicht schon wieder über 13 Jahre.
Also, ich wäre wirklich ready für Half-Life 3.
Es gibt nicht viele Spiele, die ich so oft durchgespielt habe wie Half-Life 1, Secret
of Mana vielleicht, aber ansonsten…
Es gibt nicht viele Games, die ich so oft gespielt habe.
Also…
Ich habe…
Keine Ahnung…
Ich habe Half-Life 1 bestimmt 30 Mal durchgespielt.
Insgesamt.
SoSoV1.
Danke für den Sub.
Porge.
Excellent.
Ja.
Jett, gibt es da irgendwas Spannendes?
Ich kriege langsam Hunger.
Ich bin ja heute schon früher da gewesen.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich…
Wie sieht es aus?
Lass mich mal kurz raus.
Lass mich mal kurz rausgucken.
Regnet es immer noch?
Ich glaube nicht.
Vielleicht gehe ich jetzt mal eine Runde rennen.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Ihr kennt euch aus, ne?
Ihr wisst Bescheid.
Leute, ich habe gestern das, glaube ich, ungesündeste Ever gegessen.
Tintenfischringe.
Also frittierte Tintenfischringe mit Pommes frites und so komischer Mayonnaise-Dip-Soße
für die Tintenfischringe.
Das war's.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao.
und es macht gut für sein Ziel.